vladimir putin is demanding that all
unfriendly nations now purchase oil from
them in the ruble that it doesn't make
sense for them to take us dollars or
euro and thus europe will now have to
buy gas for them from them in their own
currency and thus begins perhaps the end
of the petro dollar if you thought gas
was expensive now well you're in for a
surprise man it's going to get a whole
lot worse considering russia is a major
exporter of fossil fuels of energy of
gas of oil we also have to contend with
a major food crisis which is coming and
i hope you've been paying attention to
this one because russia also exports
massive amounts of fertilizer which we
are now not getting and planting season
is coming up harvest will be in fall
food stores last about three months so
we'll see how this plays out hopefully
it is not the apocalypse but things may
be getting crazy the new york times is
writing about smaller nuclear weapons
which could make a nuclear war without
icbms blowing up a whole bunch of cities
which is basically what i've been
talking about for some time we've also
got a story about redditors hosting
their location in ukraine volunteering
for the foreign legion and getting all
of these soldiers killed so uh man what
a day and of course we can talk about
patreon banning sydney watson joining us
to talk about all of this couple people
we got elijah schaefer
we are back in the studio tim i am happy
to be here it's been what like a year
since
black lives matter and that were burning
down your neighborhood right outside
there and they're back by the way did
you see the word west virginia i mean i
guess technically dc is not that far
yeah but i meant like so we're back i
feel like it was time to be back on the
show because antifa is back you saw vice
news said tiny dicks are back in fashion
they actually that was on that was on
their news channel they said they're
back in fashion this this was a news
headline tiny penises are back in
fashion and according to old western
tradition like the statue of david and i
thought this check this out
it makes sense that antifa would be back
in action because if tiny penises are
cool again then antifa would have to be
cool again so it's like it's like
they're both one and the same and i'm
happy to be here dude i'm happy i mean
it sounds like they're proud of it
though you know oh yeah they're they're
very they're very very proud it actually
kind of sounds like some kind of like
sour grapes yeah yeah i just said this i
go you know what there is the
correlation but i feel like this is a i
feel like i always say 2022 now feels
like 2018 all over again it's like we're
back to talking about transgender issues
antifa is back in the news we're paying
too much for gas i mean i don't know
what's going on but i feel like we've
hit the ark we've gone full circle and
we're just back to the same issue you
see you see joe biden mentioning the
fourth turning the other day
we'll talk about that stuff going into
the war but uh so so what do you do i
think most people know who you are to be
honest but what's your what do you do
for a living uh well to all the haters
who uh
wanted me to get arrested for being
inside the capitol building guess who
just got their press license renewed
from the capitol building today
so it looks like things are still good
there i'm a journalist reporter and i
also run a podcast called slightly
offensive uh and also a podcast called
you are here that's live every night
it's been a ton of fun and a ton of
craziness but guess what i'm out of
retirement because things are crazy
again so we're back to reporting we're
back on the field that's why i'm in dc
and uh just got back from ukraine out
here yeah so this is kind of crazy i'm
joking
it's not it's not not the ukraine you
were thinking of is that you cluck so
your chicken city account uh down
downstairs the the uh live chicken farm
that's now on that youtube channel
that's right i was in you cluck and i
was like trying to figure out what i was
gonna do i was trying to make sure i
saved the cluckians and then
and then i guess one who i saw who the
ghost of chicken kiev oh yeah was no he
was flapping and saving all the little
baby chickens and and he took out six
six uh chicken hawks he did yeah he did
six chicken hawks and then they shot out
his wing with the little pellets the
chicken pellets but then he got into
another bionic wing and sort of like
save the day so i'm feeling optimistic
for western chicken society and uh you
know there's a lot of chickens in our
society now we've seen a lot you know
going around one of them's running the
country so i'm happy to be here and you
have someone joining you today oh the
beautiful
the lovely recently banned on twitter
for telling too much truth savannah
hernandez from rapidfire podcast elijah
schaefer long time no see it's just like
uh you know two weeks ago i was
producing your podcast now we're here on
tim pool together uh tim thank you so
much for having me i am so excited to be
here you know i've always wanted to come
on your show you actually used to follow
me back in the day when i was doing riot
reporting then i got deleted off the
face of the earth so i was never able to
prove myself to you so i decided to
start another twitter account right
because uh i was producing for elijah
schaefer worked with alex jones for a
while then i was like let me focus in on
the independent reporting really go all
in for 2022 it's election season uh yeah
got banned again so uh
it's a lot of fun out in these streets
you know trying to tell the truth well
all right well of course ian's here it's
like running through a fire and if you
don't run fast enough you start to get
burned just keep running oh yeah keep
going yeah don't stop move
uh and hold your breath while you're
doing it you just don't have to breathe
in just breathe out when you breathe out
you actually absorb the oxygen through
your skin lydia i have a gift for you
yes oh what is it what's the gift i have
two two gifts for you to choose from oh
cool what color do you like dark blue
well it's it's purple oh oh it's purple
oh i guess it's a kind of this is how we
found out this is colorblind you know
this is a hundred-sided diet you said so
i didn't get a gift so i'm feeling a
little bit more coming tonight well you
can hold this i can come in tonight
there you go
oh let me know what you wrote you said
that you wanted to never seen dice with
so many sides
you want to prove yourself to tim yeah i
taught you well prove yourself to the
white man
there you go what do you mean how so all
you've wanted was my approval and i'm
telling you right here on the show i
always accepted you thank you thank you
so much all i've ever wanted was a white
man's approval now i'm surrounded
she said white men approve me that's the
narrative
you've made savannah here's another
sided die for you there's so many to go
around anyway i have my purple dice now
i'm very happy i'm here in the corner
pushing buttons as i always am let's get
into this ad before we get started
ladies and gentlemen we have an amazing
sponsor of tonight's show it's the daily
wire in the description below you will
see the link to the daily wires fighting
the enemy within china use promo code
timpool for 25 off of membership to
watch the enemy within the tagline what
if everything we think we know about our
leaders our society and our relationship
with the rest of the world is wrong
acclaimed journalist expert in national
threats and writer of the plot against
the president elise smith uncovers a
political coup orchestrated by america's
political corporate and media elites to
generate wealth power and prestige at
the expense of the safety and freedoms
of the amer of the american people we
are big fans of the daily wire here so
if you click the link in the description
below you can get 25 off your daily wire
membership to watch this series using
promo code tim poole shout out daily
wire guys you guys have been doing an
amazing job they uh they used actually
one of my videos and to promote their
product jeremy's razors so i think what
they're doing is absolutely fantastic
i'm totally jealous again check out the
daily wire promo code tim paul but don't
forget go to timcast.com support us
directly if you want to watch our
members only podcasts we put them up
monday through thursday at 11 pm so
we'll have one tonight and as a member
at timcast.com you're keeping all of our
journalists employed so they can write
articles every day about news you can
use things that you care about and we do
a lot of fact checking a lot of
aggregation and a lot of original
original reporting we have field
reporters on the ground reporters and we
are going to be hiring many more
reporters as we are actually looking to
hire a couple more people and i think
we're we're actually bringing on two
more uh employees thanks to all of you
helping make this company grow and we're
building our new headquarters as we
speak that being said you must smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
and share the show with your friends if
you really want to help let's read this
first story from the new york post
ladies and gentlemen putin demands
unfriendly countries use rubles to buy
russian oil and gas
russia was hit with crippling economic
sanctions after it launched a massive
military campaign against ukraine a
month ago but efforts to isolate russia
economically are complicated by the fact
that the european union is dependent on
moscow for oil and natural gas that is
used to heat homes during the winter
with the financial noose tightening and
the european union split on whether to
sanction russia's energy sector putin
hit back with a clear message if you
want your gas buy our currency russia
will continue of course supply natural
gas in accordance with volumes and
prices fixed in previously concluded
contracts putin said in a televised
meeting with top government ministers
imagine being nato and the eu and not
seeing this coming
this is this is joe biden's efforts i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna i gotta blame
joe biden for this one i mean this is
his administration in the united states
very much so the u.s leads nato
vladimir putin effectively getting off
the petrodollar requiring europe to buy
oil and gas in rubles
it's it's it's it's breaking the one
thing the united states actually has
control over or what the one thing that
we actually get value out of it is that
we control our own currency which we
make everybody buy to buy oil
so this is going to be a global
fracturing a global parallel economy is
emerging already we heard that saudi
arabia was in discussions with china to
start buying oil in yuan
threats of world war iii chaos prices
going through the roof how you guys
doing
it's part of the plan definitely i mean
besides inflation and like the supply
chain breaking up and you know there's
transgender swimmers beating out women
and we're having gay pride parades in
children's schools teaching them how to
tuck their scrotum to their butthole and
children's medical hospitals true story
um big big big uh sidestep from vladimir
putin and gasps yeah well i was going to
say besides all that obviously the best
thing that i've heard all year is that
our money might lose all of its value
and it might actually be worthless and i
know this is on purpose because i mean
if you think about destabilization of
venezuela talk about the invasion of
libya you even talk about a little bit
what was going on in syria and what
happened in iraq when leaders try to
take the oil trade off the u.s dollar if
they try to do anything like the global
currency or the african currency in
libya i mean you end up getting
sodomized and murdered in your own
countries
i know you get you get hung you get you
get let out and so i mean if for the
last like 100 years especially last few
decades if somebody tried to do this we
basically just wiped them out it makes
me wonder if we're going to allow this
to happen specifically not just with the
ruble but also with saudi arabia and
specifically the yuan in china is this
part of klaus schwab's world economic
forum idea to sort of destabilize one
empire and create a trifecta in this
movement people give that guy way too
much credit he i think he's a bad guy i
think about him but the world economic
forum is is a is an agreement among
nations to kind of see us like a lot of
bureaucrats specifically like in uh
washington obviously don't see america
as the greatest country in the world
we're like a country and there's this
movement towards a century
haven't you read about the liberal world
order
the liberal world order yeah yeah you're
not familiar uh enlighten me uh let me
let me see if i can pull it up yeah like
so there's another world order that we
need to be paying attention too many
rules no no no no no you need to
understand when they're talking about
the new world order they're talking
about the end of the liberal world order
and the emergence of a new world order
so this is the council on foreign
relations website certified by news
guard 100 out of 100 what is the liberal
world order
after world war ii the deadliest
conflict in human history countries
sought to ensure the world would never
again devolve into such horrific
violence world leaders created a series
of international organizations and
agreements to promote global cooperation
on issues including security trade
health and monetary policy the united
states has championed this system known
as the liberal world order for the past
75 years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented peace
unprecedented peace and prosperity you
know i would dispute that last sentence
but um i wouldn't dispute everything
else they're saying the council on
foreign relations overtly says after
world war ii global cooperation from
powerful world leaders creating
international organizations sought to
secure the planet um you know creating
policies on security trade health and
monetary policy when joe biden says that
there is going to be a new world order
this is what the new world order means
when bush said it when h.w bush when
clinton when hillary clinton when they
all say this what they're saying is the
liberal world order will come to an end
and there will be a new world order you
know what's that specifically called i
don't know this rhetoric is the exact
same rhetoric that you read in the un's
agenda 2030. i actually printed that out
i was reading through it this is the
exact same type of thing that they're
trying to propose right this
utopian-like society where everything's
great and we have all of these
organizations that are helping the world
pushing peace and prosperity but in
reality we see when put into practice
what this actually looks like look at
our streets right now look at
democrat-run cities if you will look at
liberal policy actually put into play
our entire country is in decay we're
deteriorating from the inside uh you
know we have a president in office who
is incapable of even forming a coherent
sentence a lot of people say that joe
biden has uh you know done a horrible
job as president well he's done a great
job of one thing destroying this country
in record time yeah he did it really
quickly huh yeah really quick really got
to give him credit for that i mean wow
it feels like it was tipping and then he
stepped into the pilot seat just as it
fell off the ledge although they did
oversee the printing of like seven or
eight trillion dollars in the last year
and a half which is terrible policy a
little bit problematic however you ever
uh everyone's sister magu
mister i call my dog mr magoo you know
you know mr magu like he can't see and
so he's like bumbling around and like
getting into all sorts of shenanigans
you know it's like an old man oh yeah
that's like that's all of us knows yeah
that's like joseph's glasses don't you
feel though when you hear this that
we've all been sold a lie and i even got
duped into this being uh from los
angeles like actually born and raised in
in southern california right there that
there was this sort of lie that we were
sold that is clearly unraveled now that
you could have this sort of liberalism
in this mecca that you could have your
cake and eat it too like you could have
money you could have freedom you could
have immigration you could have
multiculturalism and you can kind of
create this bastion of utopia
smack dab in in a desert right even your
water even though you don't have natural
water sources right in la and as we've
seen it divulge over the years is our
develop and and also then decline is
that it didn't end up really working
that well because obviously when you
have all these cultures together they
ended up self-segregating la's one of
the most segregated regions in the
country it is insane it is to the point
where you can like tell you where the
jews live where the mexicans live where
the el salvadorians live in chicago yeah
but i'm saying it you know it obviously
is touted as being diverse but it's
really segregated then the wealth
disparity there's a shrinking middle
class i mean and the confusion the laws
are not enforced it's pretty absolutely
crazy so i feel like
genuinely this liberal world order like
you said that they're doing away with is
an interesting way to get people
complacent because when you create a
liberal society that's not based on
tradition or nationalism or values but
this idea of personal liberty
individualism you start getting into
your you know your pot of choice your
vices you get into your porn addictions
you get you you know you uh pursue your
career rather than family and everyone
is just kind of like fighting they give
up their guns they're not focused on
things like self-protection and
gathering and self-sufficiency et cetera
and then we end up kind of consistent
there's a contradiction in there i mean
people who are who believe in
individuals of individualism and civil
liberties don't give up their guns
well that's what i'm saying it literally
was a deception because that's what i'm
saying they gave us this form of
liberalism this absolute kind of their
developed form of like you can have
peace in your countries the wars won't
be fought there you can make a lot of
money things can be really good your
kids can all go to college and then once
we're all in these places everyone's on
anti-anxiety and antidepressant pills
people are unhappy they're not satisfied
with their lives if you look at how
happy people are they're not full of joy
they're not content they're not
satisfied we're very divided and now
we're all in this place where we don't
have anything to unify so we don't have
a common religion not even really a
common language because i'm not talking
about spanish like have you ever heard
someone under 16 talk i don't not lately
i can't i can't tell what they're
talking about yeah but like like it's
like house
yeah i just i just meant they divided us
speak is a millennial thing dude yeah
what is this
it's l three three t leap speak it's
just the way you type like words faster
with numbers three three seven eight
interesting one three three seven my
phone yeah but that's that's an internet
culture thing that goes back a long time
i mean if you're talking about the slang
terms used by
kids yeah but that's what i'm saying is
that language is changing in a way where
it's like each generation can't even
effectively communicate with each other
not just through language but through
the mediums are changing so rapidly even
look at the app development and app
usage based off of age range i mean we
are divided and categorized to a point
to where it's the perfect time to where
we can't even we can't even agree on
basic things like on you know people are
still divided on what happened in 2020
people today can't even agree on the
most basic science and what is a man
what is a woman it's a perfect opportune
time to to to retire the current
liberalism and then institute whatever
the hell you want because we're too
divided and too weak and complacent i
believe to really effectively fight
anything like i don't think there's
anything to fight for or like we don't
we don't even know what we would be
fighting to preserve there's a great
meme right now
where it says it shows the clip from the
world from the world economic forum
saying you will own nothing and you will
be happy then it says you know
journalists say the great reset is a
conspiracy theory and the next one is
the bloomberg article saying give up
meat for lentils let your dog die let
your dog die yeah and you know whatever
people are like you alone nothing and
you'll be happy
i wanted to pop in on what you were
saying too on the entire manipulation of
our language so he and i were actually
having a conversation on the way up here
and it's kind of insane how we now are
saying biological male or biological
female now we're saying actual science
as opposed to what the left's version of
science is the language has been so
manipulated now that like elijah said in
the common day we can't even just decide
on what basic science is anymore well i
i kind of disagree i think what happened
is you have like american society moving
up and then at some point the left
started butting off like some kind of
fungus like i mean that like i don't i
don't mean as disparaging i mean
literally like fungus buds and then you
know separates yeah and that's what it
is like so people who are in the middle
or on the right who believe you know
words have meaning and you know uh
history exists
stayed going down the same path
following history following the lessons
of our ancestors and then this new group
of people split off and they have a
different language they have a different
worldview they believe crazy things
different reality really totally
different reality yeah yeah so it's it's
not
if you were to say that language changed
it it would be to imply that those
people have legitimacy now i certainly
think they control institutions i
certainly think that they are not
legitimacy though i mean if you have
power
that's what's kind of cool that's that's
their mentality there's no truth but
power i i disagree i think they're
completely illegitimate because they
make up random words that are
meaningless and you ask a supreme court
justice defined woman and just i can't
and i'm like okay you're illegitimate
and incompetent if you can't define a
basic word the same woman who said i
can't define the word woman literally a
minute later said roe v wade is about a
woman's right to terminate a pregnancy
and i'm like what what what are you
talking about you just said you didn't
know what it was you couldn't define the
word now you're baffling to me because
so again i covered the ncaas last week
and there was pro lgbtq protesters there
you know standing up for leah thomas and
i'm standing there talking to these
college-aged kids and it's such a
surreal moment when you have someone
look at you in your face and go yes a
woman can have a penis yes men can get
pregnant and yes men can have periods
and again you know this is rhetoric that
we've seen time and time again this is
nothing new but actually hearing
somebody say that to you to your face
bold face completely believing it just
shows me how far gone we've become like
as a country to where there's no basis
in reality at all anymore this is why
people talk about national divorce it's
why they talk about civil war it's not
so much about look i don't care those
people can believe whatever they want
they can watch whatever movies they want
to make and do that and then what do we
get we get the daily wire making their
own razors we get the daily wire making
their own movies we are certainly
interested in moving that direction as
well with our own cultural content we
just need to stop
trying to be a part of their club that's
that's one of the most frustrating
things to me like i don't care if these
people walk around thinking that they're
you know uh clowns juggling bananas like
that's cool dude you do your thing man
i'm gonna be hanging out here with my
friends like having a beer and playing
guitar that's our thing you do your
thing but the problem is conservatives
keep begging to be in their club and
they need to stop doing it republicans
do it all the time they're they freak
out because right now gop racist is
trending on twitter it's like so what
who cares they're so weak and pathetic
there's so many spineless rhinos in our
congress right now in our just political
space as a whole they're so spineless
they're so pathetic and the reason why
conservatism as a whole has completely
deteriorated is because people like matt
schlapp who's supposed to be the creator
of the conservative political action
committee is coming forward and saying
oh leah thomas's journey we really need
to have empathy about it because uh you
know her story is important are you
freaking kidding me right now
conservatism is pathetic in the modern
day well it is i agree with that but i
also agree with what matt was saying if
these women at the ncaa don't care to
speak up if none of the if none of their
family members will speak up then they
deserve they deserve whatever whatever
they're experiencing that's not what
matt was saying matt was saying that he
thinks that we should have empathy
towards leah thomas i completely
disagree again i'm not a female athlete
i'm not the one that should be
protesting you and i are actually
talking about this uh before the start
of the show why did these females even
compete with thomas why didn't because
they liked it
because
this called the play this sport
this is one of the most frustrating
things to me because the ncaa women have
publicly come out and agreed with leah
thomas and supported her and the only
person who didn't the only person so far
to come out complaining is the person
who got bumped by one space
16th place but that got deleted
what teammate so that is who i
interviewed last week that's the news we
broke tucker carlson played it on his
show her teammate rose pouch uh she
spoke out on behalf of her said her
teammate was crying all right but she
wasn't in the finals either right uh no
she was in the final she got first place
in the 200 uh yard free she spoke out
against the thomas because she watched
her teammate cry as thomas took that
final spot again uh i can't pronounce
her name correctly rick
yes that's her name uh she was going to
respect someone coming out and actually
speaking so that's that's what i'm
saying tim so it's like it's not that
all of these athletes aren't speaking
out it's that they're being completely
silenced now we made national news with
that it's completely been deleted off of
twitter you can't find it anywhere all
of the national news articles that were
linked to her interview completely gone
right now this is the point in this that
i wanna that i wanna bring up is first
of all matt schlapp saying that we need
to have empathy on this person's journey
who by the way has a clear and present
bulge actually bigger than mine so i'm
taking some notes here but i will say
you know that's that's completely crap
and conservatism definitely is in the
position to where people are fighting to
conserve things that do not exist and
have not existed for some time including
this entire country for at least a
hundred years as they've been divul uh
we've been developing into some crazy
globalist empire but with the specific
thing with with the the swimmers i don't
think it's enough to just say like it's
their fault because we've gotten in used
to everybody in every field in every
department institution we already assume
they have to be activists because
everybody everybody seems to be one
journalists are activists professors are
activists and now we're saying look
there's people who just want to swim
they do not want to get involved in
political things in fact one of the
greatest things i have found and has
kept me sane has been lifting weights
getting back in shape and i go onto
twitter and i put like one thing up like
yeah hey you know i did my 5x5 at 225 on
chest i'm excited to hit a goal and
there's all these bros that get in there
that are like oh man what's your squat
what's your this what's your that and
i'm like dude you're complicating
something i picked up heavy things
i put them back down i know there's a
science to this i know people get really
involved i'm not doing that where are
these girls dance
there's a point to be said to this
though good question but there's a point
to be said that's why i don't care no no
because but here's the point what you're
asking for and i'm saying this genuinely
some people i've i know people that are
into swimming for instance and they just
do it to clear their mind they do to get
their mind off the world and focus on
the goals
my point is as i'm saying people always
try to complicate things a lot of these
swimmers are put in a tough position
that they their scholarships might ride
on this they might come from
impoverished families
listen and maybe that just maybe when
you're when you're focused on breaking
generational like wealth gaps and you go
to a nice school and you're trying to
swim and get your family out of that
poverty that idea of getting out of
poverty is more important to you than a
social issue like transgenders and you
don't know what to do so what's
happening in our world is no matter
who's out there we are demanding of them
to be political activists what should be
happening is this discussion should be
happening at a senior level with
administrators and with individuals who
are put in those political positions to
try to debate whether something is
ethical but the swimmers themselves i
don't blame them for not knowing what to
do because like that girl who was scared
these are genuine people who are going
even if i speak out will it change
anything and they don't have they're not
they don't they can't have they can't
afford what you want no no no no no no
no no we're stopping right there bro i
am sick and tired of hearing about
spineless people who don't stand up for
themselves who think they're entitled to
everything that's one of the big issues
i have with the left they come out and
they say we should get free college we
should get free vet i shouldn't have to
do anything for it these swimmers won't
come out their dads won't come out their
moms won't come out now there was one
woman who spoke anonymously and then you
come here and you say they don't have
all of this bro
not only did i come from the gutter but
i've consistently stood up for my values
i've had people on this show who have
been censored over and over again and i
know there are hard limitations because
there's certain things that makes that's
difficult for either uri to talk about
on our shows but i quit a corporate gig
i tried to break a contract with
millions of dollars because they wanted
me to do woke bs now for me i'm not
saying anybody has to have my back on
that i'm saying i take care of myself i
don't think i'm entitled to or owed
anything so when i'm at a company and
they say you want the money we're paying
you we have you under contract you're
going to do woke stuff i said no i won't
and they said well you better and i said
i guess i'll just sit here or you can
break my contract but they said
political commentators can i was not a
political commentator when i worked for
abraham to some extent though but you're
in the visuals you're into somewhat of
entertainment like a lot of these people
are just athletes and they're like dude
i didn't ask for this i don't know
what's wrong with a lot of their
athletes trying to figure it out so we
got to give them some time i don't want
to be political activists they want to
be able to just focus on their sport i
completely agree with what you're saying
tim but i also think that this is your
passion this is your career right
swimming is those girls passion they
don't want to be political activists the
big reason why their parents don't want
to speak out for them is because the
daughters ask the parents hey you know
what just don't do it i don't want to
face the repercussion i don't want the
ncaa coming after me the ncaa told these
athletes don't mention leah thomas's
name in the locker room do not speak to
any media so the fact that i even got
that interview that's why it went so
viral because the ncaa has been
silencing these women i understand what
you're saying tim because i'm the exact
same way i'm hardline and i say stand up
for your rights stand up for your
country or you will lose everything but
at the same time we do have to remember
we're in this spot because not everybody
is a political activist unfortunately
that i'm not going to uh i'm not going
to stand up for people who haven't asked
for it yeah like it is the most insane
thing to me that you have people being
like we must defend these young women
who are actively publicly supporting
leah thomas i'm like dude have like what
are you talking about what's that i
don't deserve it but i don't think i'm
supporting leah
they're acting like they're mad when
they're not no no because that's not
even the point i'm saying
we tend to be in politics and i'm not
saying you but just in general is
reactionary where we expect that people
move on our time we consume stories by
the daily there are people that i met i
met an uber driver that didn't even know
there was a war in ukraine okay like he
didn't even know that was happening
people in the world are sometimes so
focused on a goal that they even
disconnect that's even required of them
to get off social media etc and they
don't know what's going on
there is a problem that we see
the problem is is that the swimmers need
to see how big of an issue this is of
letting a man compete against women in a
way that will always beat them will out
qualify them and would fundamentally
change the country i'm saying i don't
believe all of them see that because i
remember being around non-political
people who are like okay this is weird
but i'm being told this is right
especially if they don't have any more
if they don't have any moral absolution
or maybe they're not even that high iq
then i'm saying they might be saying i
don't know what to do so before i'm
judging them for not swimming i'm saying
i think a lot of them are weighing their
they are weighing their options and more
importantly like you said how you would
have turned down a contract i think a
lot of them will lose out on their
opportunities and i think this is where
you started enough of them are willing
to stand up but you see them getting
birthed somebody is going to get red
pill somebody might stand up and it
might say
how long has it been this has been going
on for 14 years in the public spotlight
if we track the data going into the new
york times 14 years 14 years parents are
not speaking up they're not going to
meetings the fathers and the mothers are
not showing up to meetings and saying we
want rule changes they don't care not
only that what i'm telling you why i'm
particularly frustrated with this is
that even wrecka giorgi the one person
who got bumped from the finals in her
complaint said i stand i fully stand
with leah thomas and you know she is no
different from me or any other d1
swimmer who wakes up every day and i
said then i am not going to do the work
for you and no one else should if they
have an issue with this they need only
politely say they could they could wear
a pink ribbon they could wear a little
ribbon that says like i am protesting
this but i'll keep keep going because i
want my scholarships but they're these
are i am sick and tired of people who
are aware of what's going on and
apparently according to mothers they are
but they won't speak publicly who are
refusing to stand up and stand up for
their rights for whatever reason they
expect other people to do it for them
it's not going to happen
the left goes out and they throw bricks
through windows and they burn down
buildings and they've literally killed
dozens of people in the george floyd
riots kamala harris then helped bail
these people out 13 joe budden staffers
donated to help bail these people out
and republicans are like but i'm going
to get called a racist yeah i'm sorry
man if you are unwilling to stand up for
yourself for your children if you were a
father unwilling to stand up for your
daughter and you think i'm going to come
out and be like i will stand up for you
i'm not going to do it
it's not these people are this goes back
to okay look at what we saw for the past
two years with the coveted lockdowns
right people's businesses getting shut
down all of us being forced to mask up
all of these things that we had to do
because the government told us to i've
been saying this since
15 days too slow the spread was
originally talked about this will not
end until the masses decide that it does
you are completely right in that time
this does not end until the female
athletes decide that enough is enough
they're going to stand up they're going
to push back and they're going to put an
end to it i don't think they care i
think you guys are are putting this view
on them they definitely care no no no no
no no no no no no no no i i'll tell you
this so this is genuinely true and this
is where i actually want to agree with
you about the father thing yes but it's
deeper than that my point is is i'm not
saying because they care that i'm
fighting and i know this is not a
popular statement but number one i don't
expect women to be the fighters and the
champions of social movements and of the
country i think they can i think there's
many women who've done many great things
but i understand i don't believe it's in
their nature i believe in traditional
design and i think a lot of these women
women tend to be more submissive not all
women especially modern feminist women
but i think that's the natural design
and i don't think and i said would blame
their fathers more or their boyfriends
or husbands more than them i would do
that but on the site
yeah
majority of millennial
was it 70 percent of wendell democrats
are female
feminism the i mean i think you're you
have it backwards women are the ones who
are consistently over the past 20 years
demanding social change yeah but this
yeah but it's in one direction so my my
point is not in this direction and so
why aren't these feminine doing this
this is my point is i'm saying that
aside because you'd have to ascribe to a
traditional worldview or believe in god
to really believe that probably or be
very well versed in science what i am
going to say is why i care about it is
not because i'm not trying to get that
17th place person i'm not petitioning so
that she can get back into 16th i don't
care about this because of them i care
about this because of what it means for
our country and for future generations
if we accept as a whole even if that
pool they all cared about you know they
don't care and whatever they want to let
it happen okay fine so if there's a
bunch of people in a house and they just
want to create a meth lab and they're
all cool with that should i be cool with
that no should i fight against the idea
of having major drug labs in houses
across the country yes even if they are
all for it and they're like well you
know the neighbors aren't mad about it
like dude we're not gonna have a country
where you can just create meth labs and
blow up houses sorry not gonna be okay
with that very very very different no it
but yes it's dif no it's different when
you see something that's that's toxic
that's bad that's a social issue i'm
using a physical issue that people could
understand to a social issue when you're
allowing something to go out and not
just to happen because remember it's not
just the people in the in the pool the
swimmers are even the least important to
me on this you have espn et cetera
interviewing this there this is being
reaffirmed nationally and as you know on
this show right now if i were to say
what i was really feeling about this
issue this live stream would get pulled
meaning it big tech is in on this as
well saying this is normal and normal
people are not and that's what i'm
saying
this is bs and i'm going to fight the
issue even if they won't because i don't
accept this for the comments i don't
agree with you on that i don't i don't
disagree with you on that my frustration
is with people who don't send it for
themselves i'm saying if we're going to
get pissed too
if we're talking specifically about the
greater issue by all means everybody who
wants to complain about it has a right
to complain about it yeah when we're
specifically talking about wreckage as
the one person to publicly complain
because she's the one person who got
bumped i'm like dude you had every
opportunity to speak up you didn't and
you're only complaining now because
you're the one person who got bumped
18th place isn't complaining because she
wouldn't have made it anyway and 16th
place isn't complaining because she did
make it i just don't see any principle
among those people and we already have
people mentioning this and i've answered
this several times who are saying if i
spoke up for my children i would lose my
job well then i understand what you find
to be more important security for your
family is more important than what your
children are going through with society
and with culture so what if i i'll i
said this before and i'll say it again
if if you're more concerned about you
know keeping your job and keeping your
income at least you'll know your kids
had a good meal you know when when in 20
years they're in the gulag sometimes
speaking up is actually dangerous the
founding fathers had to keep it under
wraps if they'd spoke up against george
they would have been executed on the
block oh i completely agree the the
parents could have come together uh on
one night all all sat down and said do
we all agree we have a problem here okay
now that we've all come together we can
we can unanimously issue a statement
under our names because we all know we
have each other's yeah leah thomas
technically isn't doing anything wrong
she's following the rules so changing
the rules is where the key it lies how
do you best change the rules
on this because i do want to make this
point because i agree with a lot of what
you guys are saying but this is when
censorship comes into play so we all
know that many people on the right wing
many of these independent journalists
are being censored and why is that
that's because we are going out on the
ground and we are
elevating those unheard voices so right
now you guys are saying you're not
hearing from any of these athletes and
why is that it's because espn is
platforming
platforming leah thomas that's because
all of the mainstream is platforming
leah thomas as a hero they're not
platforming the uh adults and the
parents that are speaking out they're
not platforming platforming the app
they're not speaking out but they aren't
because i interviewed them last week and
guess what all of those interviews are
gone did you see any of my work from
last week why why did why did why did
the mother
why did she come out anonymously to the
new york post
again there but there's also parents
that came out they were not anonymous
they came out last week they had their
names they had their picture up on the
article but those stories are not
elevated and they're not promoted so i
understand what you're saying but
understand too that big tech is allowed
to uh you know regulate what the
narrative is so there are people that
are speaking out there are athletes that
are speaking out but their footage is
being deleted they are being censored
and they are being silenced because they
are not the popular uh you know
narrative that the big tech wants to
push oh yeah the swimmers could have you
know chosen to protest the swim mm-hmm i
agree i completely agree with you on
that but i'm saying that there are
voices
have publicly supported leah thomas and
we're talking in circles now so i think
it's just i i get it you know if there
are people in this country have an issue
with what's happening in these schools
then i you know i actually i agree
if we're talking specifically about the
ncaa right now my problem is i am sick
and tired of the past 10 years where
there are people who know about the
problems who refuse to speak up i think
it was clinton clifton duncan said the
same thing he says he said something to
the effect of i am more what do you say
i'm more i have more disdain for those
who know what's happening and refuse to
speak than those who those who are
ignorantly participating in it something
that effect and that's where i've been
at for some time right the people who
say to me i know what they're doing to
my children in school that they're
grooming their kids and that they're
making up lies about you know the don't
say gay bill man if you come to me and
tell me you know what these teachers are
doing to your kids and that you'd rather
have your job than save your kids from
that i think you've got a very serious
problem with what's going to happen to
your children that's mind blowing but
here but here's where where i have to to
think and not just react
i agree and and we're sitting in a room
of people who have chosen like you said
to not
allow what could happen bad to us or our
friends or family inhibit us from
pursuing what we believe god has called
us to or the universe or whatever you
ascribe to
my point is is that i am saddened that
in every culture there are warriors and
there are people who fight in an age of
information and intellectual property a
lot of the fighting happens in the
intellectual centers it's like back to
rome or to greece it's the battle of the
wits and of course there still is real
war and their people end up you know you
know deleting themselves with two shots
at the back of the head things still
happen there's still violence but
overall the fight is happening on the
public square and so a lot of different
souls that wouldn't basically not make
it on traditional battlefield are
somehow successful it basically values
uh intellect rather than just physical
might now i am saying that i understand
that wars have always been fought and
right now this war is being fought and i
don't mind you and i take hits all the
time everyone at this table does it is
so sad to me now that everybody is
forced to join the war now again to
concede to your point on this there are
times when the village gets raided when
the kingdom is under siege and every
able-bodied man i mean look at ukraine
they're not letting the young men leave
where it's like there is a time to fight
but i'm saying my point is is that
sometimes i think we're rushing people
because we're more alarmist and see
what's going on 14 years yes but but to
some yes but more people wake up you
would think after covid that everybody
would have woken up to what's going on
but they still didn't because the sleep
was so deep what's the second amendment
say
um it's the it's the uh right to a
well-armed militia basically the
security of a free state the right to
keep and bear arms et cetera uh a
well-regulated militia being necessary
for a free state and a militia was just
the people who were armed who would come
together when needed we didn't have
police forces back in the day we
actually had local militia that's how
things were dealt with so if somebody
stole they'd rather round up all the
people and be like you know like arrest
them and bring them to the magistrate or
whatever
and uh the founding fathers understood
everybody would have to fight to defend
their land what i see now is we are in a
for we're now in year 14 of a major
culture war and it's going back to like
you know economic collapse the rise of
critical race theory occupy wall street
gamergate all of these things and you
have people who are like i've been
watching what's been happening since
donald trump social issues were a major
component of why many millennials voted
for donald trump and still they say as
we're as bad as it has gotten and as
craziest things have gotten i still
refuse to fight
but i'll be upset about it i guess now i
don't think anybody has to do anything i
mean look if you want something you have
to fight for it if you don't fight for
it i assume you don't want something i'm
not going to complain that these female
swimmers don't care enough to speak out
but that's reality are you saying no
nobody can avoid the war i'm asking if
that's what you're saying or what i'm
saying is to put it simply
if you place a person between two roads
and one is just keep swimming and and
keep your head down and one is speak up
and stand up for your rights they're all
choosing the road they they think is
better for them that means they don't
care enough about leah thomas to
actually say anything i'm sure they're
upset about it because you can be you
know you can be mad about your choices
and choose the lesser of two evils or
something slightly worse
if you if if people really cared about
this if parents really cared about their
children
they would look if you really cared
about your kids and you knew teachers
were grooming your kids you would be
homeless to save your child from that
right
let me ask you both which would you
prefer your child spends eight hours a
day being groomed by cult members
and you have you make fifty sixty
thousand dollars a year or you're
homeless and your kids are safe with you
so whether we'd have our kids hang out
with pete buddhist husband
or would we be okay like i'm i'm like
i'm talking about what's going on in
florida yeah i mean
the kid the kids matter but but i will
say on to the under that point real fast
this is where i think that that we're
getting confused on the argument and
it's not going in circles
just like i watch the the gay pride
parade in austin in that elementary
school i'm going i don't blame the kids
that are i think they're like eight nine
years old 10 years old i don't blame the
kids for you know anything about that i
would blame the teachers and my fight
would be with the teachers i i know this
is unpopular but i'm gonna
i view people who are asleep a lot of
people who are asleep with the same way
that i view children is that they are
not aware of what's going on and i don't
assume they all know what's going on so
i keep accountable those that do and if
there are swimmers that are out there
that fully are aware of what's going on
they know what they're doing is wrong
they choose to do it then yes i would
call them out and i'm not asking you a
specific question because you're
homeless you would rather be homeless
safe with your kids yeah cause i'd
figure out another way to make money
well so the response we get every time i
bring this up and we have super chats
right here saying this exact thing is i
can't speak up because i would lose my
job you know and my kids need to eat and
things like that
in west virginia
school you think it's the second most
trump supporting state in the country
you'd think the schools are going to be
republican they're not yeah the school
board members who were voted in are woke
there are kids in west virginia schools
who are being groomed and indoctrinated
and there are parents who say i don't
care enough
to risk my security and that includes my
children's security now i can fully
understand you prioritize your kid
having a full belly over
being away from groomers i personally
disagree
i don't have kids so maybe i can't speak
to it and that's fine but i typically
ask most people and they give me the
same response i would rather be homeless
and unsure of how i'm going to eat and
my kids than leave my children in the
hands of a groomer for eight hours every
day at these schools my question is then
why so many parents do it and i think
it's because the parents many of them
don't know and i'll and i'll totally uh
contend with that and we're fighting
every day to inform them
but many of the parents do know and tell
me well i don't want to lose my job okay
look no disrespect you've chosen it we
had uh um we had andrew heaton on
and i was explaining he's a very you
know mill the road guy and he says both
sides you know i take issue with still
libertarian and uh uh i think
yeah i said the the right makes their
arguments based off of
the they they present facts they can
prove to you and then from those facts
will give you their opinion on why their
policy ideas are correct the left will
lie to you about what the problem is
because the ends justify the means to
convince you to side with them
and his response was that i was
describing the left as you know bad or
evil and the right as moral and i said
no no i'm not
the left literally will tell you this by
any means necessary in their books they
write the strategy of of keeping secrets
they there's undercover video being
exposed right now something from
accuracy and media was going viral where
teachers are saying we're going to
change the language but keep crt in
schools we can't let the parents know
this is exactly what they'll tell you
they're doing what i said to them was if
you think that i'm describing them as
good or evil it's because you view one
side as good or evil not because i've
ascribed that to them the right does
this they'll say look at this fact it's
not from me it's proof right therefore
here's my my argument on moral issues or
whatever the left will say here's a
manipulation to trick you into agreeing
with me we see it all the time in the
press these are tendencies not absolutes
when it comes to somebody who says you
know i can't speak up because my kids or
whatever
what they're really saying is deep down
they know
their kid being this position is very
wrong and bad
but they prefer to keep their kid with
the groomer than lose their job
actions speak louder than words and if i
could answer now too i would have the
same exact answer as elijah to say you
know i would rather be homeless and take
care of my child and protect my kids but
what you just laid out there tim is
exactly where our country is where it is
today because if push comes to shove and
i think about this all the time with the
second amendment right if push comes to
shove how many americans do you think if
the police were at their door right now
and said give us your guns or we will
kill you how many of them would just
give up their guns willingly and give up
their second amendment and rights people
do not understand that standing up for
your rights means you are willing to die
for your rights and you need to be ready
to die for your rights for your freedoms
every single day people don't seem to
understand that because we've been so
cuddled as a society because we face no
real
challenges as you know in this country
and so people so willingly give away
their rights and freedoms which is why
for the past year we've watched people
say i don't want to get vaccinated but
i'm going to do it to keep my job
because the government told me to do it
if the government tells me to take four
or five six boosters i will do it
because they told me to people do not
have
the uh mentality that they need to fight
for the rights and die for them and they
don't get it which is why we're here
let's let's jump to the story um about
censorship we have this from timcast.com
patreon bans users for content on other
platforms without warning yep
this week patreon which hosts paid
content for creators has banned two
well-known creators with platform for
appearances and content shared on other
media platforms on tuesday sydney watson
host of you are here i've heard of that
show on blaze tv was banned from the
platform watson does not regularly post
content to the site but was banned over
hate speech according to a notice from
patreon watson's program on blaze tv
covers current topics just disney
employee walkouts i think we know that
plus we have elijah here so we can we
can move on and we also had um josh uh
location is that you pronounce it late
cash i think
he was banned hours after appearing on
infor so these are two accounts but it's
not just you know these individuals on
patreon it's also tucker carlson got
censored on twitter
and
uh charlie kirk
and the babylon b so it looks like we're
starting to see censorship kicking back
up for a while there there was a small
lull right censorship was huge news for
a long period of time all of a sudden
now the the reason i would say it looks
like we're starting to see things kick
into high gear is that tucker carlson
getting censored is big i mean he's
prominent but seeing sydney watson get
her patreon banned when she doesn't even
post to it is very interesting to me why
would they shut down sydney's patreon
here's my thoughts
she was getting about a thousand bucks a
month from patreon passively this helps
sydney exist and do work and be
influential the midterm elections are
coming up and just one month ago mike
bloomberg said the democrats are going
to get wiped out the polls are showing
as the past few months democrats are
getting wiped out mike bloomberg was
interesting because he said the reason
they're going to get wiped out is
because americans perceive democrats as
being too obsessed with cultural issues
and not economic issues well why would
people believe that i mean if you watch
the mainstream media
sure you might hear like cnn and msnbc
will talk some about the democrats but
for the most part no they're trying to
prop them up it's channels like ours
it's shows like yours elijah with sydney
that are bringing up the cultural issues
democrats are engaged in what the
schools are actually fighting for the
teachers are trying to keep these things
a secret they don't want parents to know
about it if the parents didn't know
about it they'd probably not think
democrats were fighting for it because
people like you or i expose this stuff
there's a perception growing among
regular voters that democrats are
obsessed with cultural issues
then they ban sydney watson seemingly
out of the blue for no reason why they
want to start stripping away influence
like we saw in 2018 the first patreon
purge it happened just after the
midterms i think just around the same
time as the midterms we saw carl
benjamin get booted and then all of a
sudden a bunch of people staged a mass
exodus i think it may have been before
the midterms actually it's no surprise
that right before democrats start losing
their allies in big tech and media start
coming after prominent influencers who
are making democrats look bad
yeah you know first of all on the sydney
issue we have to focus on this i'll
comment on josh in a second
but number one that city didn't use the
platform or post anything anymore is
clear evidence that she didn't do
anything
wrong on the platform we know that
patreon does ban for activity outside
the platform in fact i ended up doing a
meeting and pretending to be a take one
of their
user meetings with their engineered team
and pretended like i cared and i
recorded this i don't know if i should
say that but ended up recording the
audio and kept asking them questions of
whether or not that they were if i never
published it so this is not illegal
hopefully uh but i also was like i was
talking to them and i genuinely this is
years ago like what 2018 are about i
think of 2018 i was like hey i just want
to know if you guys are for free speech
and every time i'd ask them a question
they would just kind of like dodge it
and it was nothing came of it matt
christensen got on a call recorded it
years ago do you remember the 2018 when
matt christensen like recorded his phone
call whatever
yeah yeah so he literally got on there
and when he was asked about it whether
to free if they care about free speech
they were just like i don't know so
basically they didn't want to answer so
i looked back i had tweets in 2018
saying i gotta leave and my first tweet
of january 1st of 2019 was like my goal
this year is to leave patreon and i did
and i lost thousands of dollars
prematurely because i knew that this
would happen but with sydney watson
there's three things that are really
vital here number one
sydney is not a religious zealot nut
right-wing extremist you know person
some white straight male that we got to
get off because it's going to bring the
nationalist fascist government back
sydney is a cultured
atheist very well-spoken well-researched
individual who mostly just puts out on
her own channel hyper researched well
thought out scripted videos she has no
history of making extremist statements
she's never part of been a part of an
extremist group
the closest thing she's ever done to
extremism was run a men's right
conference in australia another country
for their rights and to fight for them
which was controversial in australia
which everything's controversial there
but more importantly the ironic part is
we run a show together now and the whole
reason why we want to show together
she's the same one who actually brings
some logic and some straightforwardness
and helps keep me back in reality where
she lives while i'm out in space so it's
like cindy's reputation
is actually for being calculated for
thinking things through and she's known
for if she doesn't know stuff will say i
actually haven't researched that i don't
know that so you're taking just a normal
girl who's literally from australia who
doesn't have a history of anything gets
deleted you know it's targeting for a
specific reason and i i'm wondering
though with this as they deleted her i
wonder if they're just testing who else
they can delete because if they can get
somebody who doesn't post but is still
making money i feel like it gives them
the green light to go well let's go
after other people too there's no
evidence nothing happens i mean it was
it was three and a half years ago
you know we had we saw these
conversations i will say for sydney i i
reached out to her she said it was like
i asked if it was like a background
thing for her meaning she has it it's
available to people but she doesn't
actively post there so it exists but
it's not like she was using the platform
and ran afoul of their rules
so
as for for josh i really have to
question why he was on patreon josh uh
lakesh lakota you know you know are you
familiar with wrong opinion podcast i'm
not familiar but i would like to comment
on sydney very quickly before you move
on to josh i would just say that uh this
is the soft introduction to people
getting banned from banks which we're
already seeing here in america look at
what just happened in canada sorry go
ahead well no no
the point i was bringing up with josh is
that all of this happened almost four
years ago i think it's fair to say three
and a half years ago because it was
three three years in five months so for
uh cindy to get banned she got banned
for what uh carl benjamin got banned for
the exact same thing
off platform behavior
so so again i'll say this like what what
did she do do you have any she existed
well for for sydney she's not
she wasn't using patreon as like her
core income
and so you know i don't really care if
you have a patreon right now and you're
like oh i don't really care about i
don't even think twice if it's gone it's
gone it's here it's whatever there's
money i'm like okay i get it but uh the
reason i brought up josh is that he put
his career on a platform where over
three years ago
lauren southern was nuked overnight
without warning and then carl benjamin
the ceo said we'll never do this again
we will issue warnings to people let
them know because we don't want to take
their income and then someone dug up a
live stream where carl benjamin was
making a point about he was arguing with
people who he says were were all right
and so he used a racist term to describe
them and his point was you are exactly
the way you described these people for
that patreon banned his account without
warning for off-platform behavior
and then reported that you know he said
a racial slur and got banned
three years later josh is still using
the platform i mean like at a certain
point there is
i think it's wrong they shouldn't
abandon but it's almost it's also like
bro if you if you if like antifa puts up
a big flyer saying we're having an
antifa party and we're going to beat up
elijah shafer and then elijah schaefer
is like i'm going to go to that that was
my job for like 18 months no but i mean
like specifically saying like true
like a good career choice like this like
it's one thing to be in a public space
that everyone's allowed to access but
patreon is a private company that i do
understand and the moment they took
action against lauren and carl i was
like i'm out red flag yeah after lauren
i i actually talked to the ceo and he
was like dude we're trying you got to
understand i argued with them and i even
i even you know
i'm pretty sure he didn't even know what
he was talking about when it came to
lauren southern when i talked to him
when it happened with carl benjamin i
was like this dude lied to us so they
invited us into their business let's say
it was a sandwich shop that had a big
sign saying elijah shaffer will get
punched in the face it's like would you
go in there you know like you know
they're coming after you it's a monday
or like they're going to spit in your
food they're not going to i get what
you're saying like there are there are
so many opportunities i think you've
seen too where like genuinely and i i
want to hear sav's opinion on this
someone who is just fresh off the delete
train uh
is where
i do get i totally understand this i
have a hard time commenting since i run
primarily my career on youtube and i
know youtube hates me and i know that i
could lose my channels any second and i
know we're all kind of playing that game
i would say i think josh just probably
bet on the fact that i don't mean this
disrespectfully to him that it's more of
a niche smaller podcast he's not lauren
southern he's not going on some ship
crews and wearing it's okay to be white
t-shirts into australia and whatnot he's
not doing these things he's not getting
the national press he's got a niche pod
podcast and i love lauren southern so
much but but i meant like he's got this
way where you think well i'm probably
beyond scrutiny like even sydney or
whatever is raising in in in her profile
she's been very successful recently uh
and throughout her
her career i think she'll eventually get
a million subs pretty soon and so she
could be a target but not me and so
that's what we're kind of seeing like
with sav where it's like and i'm not
mean this to disrespect to you either
where savs learn this the hard way is
like it doesn't matter how big you are
it matters what you're doing it really
does it's inverted actually the bigger
you are the harder it is to ban you
because it makes too big of a splash
yeah that's why when it came to learn to
code twitter mostly banned smaller
accounts
i so when the learn to code thing was
happening and they were banning people
it was mostly people with a few hundred
followers who are just engaging and
sharing and talking i tweeted learn to
code several times
nothing ever happened to me my account
was just too big it would have been too
big of an issue and they said oh no so
they can get rid of as many of these
conservatives as possible saying learn
to code and none of them are big enough
to actually make a splash that's what
they're going for so
banning josh is actually entirely
predictable if you're a small creator if
you're a new channel with maybe only 100
to several thousand followers and you go
on youtube you'll be banned in two
seconds if you go on patreon you'll be
banned in two seconds this is why i say
if you're just starting out now rumble
is the place to be
absolutely rumble or mines but rumble is
going to be growing plus there's locals
integration with rumble i've got my
issues with locals but they're still
substantially better than patreon i
can't imagine like there's no reason you
couldn't just go to locals you know you
build your business on the platform of
someone who expressly says like we're
going to destroy you and we want to and
then you're shocked when they do well
and that's the thing too that we all
should have learned from alex jones
being banned right it was alex jones he
was crazy he was a conspiracy theorist
everyone was like yeah yeah he deserves
to be banned no one else is going to get
banned and then as the years have
progressed we've seen more and more
people get banned and like you just
talked about tim you know if you're an
independent journalist who's just
getting into the game
you are not going to make it if you're
willing to tell the truth you're not
going to make it if you're actually
trying to go out on the street and go
get those interviews and go viral it's
very difficult i mean yeah yeah rumble
sure um it's growing it's a new platform
but i mean think about the fact that you
candace owens elijah schaefer stephen
crowder a lot of these big names you
guys got really popular back in the day
when youtube was still the wild wild
west when you could still say whatever
you wanted on twitter now it's really
difficult to break into the space unless
you're on an alternative platform like
truth social or locals rumble all that i
i agree i disagree um i got big well
after the censorship was taking effect i
mean my my main growth was in 2019. so
that's when it hit to the major news
show yeah about youtube yeah they were
they they uh it was 2018 in may when
youtube nuked my channels across the
everyone's channels got nuked across the
board and it was only last year the
censorship got removed on google for tim
cast so we actually were hindered for a
long time i think the issue was that for
one i'm i'm a workaholic i was work i
was producing
i think four hours of content every day
more than any other talk radio host or
podcaster and weekends with no days off
that helped me kind of push through this
barrier they're setting up
and then last year i mentioned on this
show that you couldn't even google
search tim cast the channels or any of
our videos if that if you took the title
of one of our segments and put it in
google facebook would come up you could
even try and search for youtube and then
immediately after that the next day the
filters were removed
so we actually went through all of that
we had the the alternative influencer
network study that was published by all
these major outlets that tried claiming
i was the center no joke of like this
vast network of the alt-right or
something craziest thing ever claimed
that i had done segments of people i'd
never met before claimed that chris
raygun
had had coordinated with richard spencer
like the levels of lies and smith chris
reagan chris raygun oh i don't know who
that is you know the song punch a nazi
no
i know
i don't
i'm sure that yelled at
it's a satirical song uh based on
paparazzi by lady gaga where he mocks
the left for thinking everyone's a nazi
he he did delete he unlisted the video
because i guess the left told him it was
bad and he like apologized or something
for and removed it which i think is
ridiculous and silly because it was a
great point he was making but uh the
point being the true era of free speech
on youtube was 2006. after after google
bought them in 2000 and 2006 there was
about four months and then they made
their first band and it was warren 25.
go back and watch warren 25 videos if
you can find any of them he had to
change his name warren 25 smash he came
back then they banned that he would
swear profanities of george bush to end
the war just this canadian dude oh so
lit and he gave me inspiration to speak
my mind dude i get so sad that i'll
never get to experience youtube editing
come on you can go back and watch it
but a lot of late nights video chatting
avocado his name was literally not the
nikk it was n-i-g-g-a and avocado he's a
white guy on youtube for a long time and
then he was it wasn't even as bad as
this now all he had to come out was be
like yo i didn't know we weren't
supposed to be using the n-word in our
names and then everyone was like cool
and he's still popular he's like one of
the most viral people in the world he's
like sorry try doing that today start
call yourself n word cast irl it's not
gonna work there is no peak of youtube
there there isn't one i mean maybe we'll
see it once youtube's completely
obliterated but uh i was at the uh
tribeca film festival ceremony thing i
got invited to back in i think 2012.
this is 20 i'm pretty sure this is 2012.
and there was this very popular youtube
group i'll keep let them keep their
privacy and they were talking to me
about how they were like man youtube
used to be amazing back in like 2009
2010 they were like we'd put up a video
and we'd get like 5 million views now
we're lucky if we get half a million
that was in 2012 they were saying that
vice they got all of their big play on
their documentaries in like 09 and 2010
and then after that it's like on average
they get like 50 000 now so people are
like
the the oh man the best time was four or
five years ago no there's there's
there's no
it's getting bad it's getting worse
but i think the reality is
right now the latter is being pulled up
behind you there are different periods
where everyone thinks like this period
was the peak this period was the peak i
don't know when the peak was to be
honest maybe 2012 but maybe not even
because your real opportunity for
virality in the era of reddit and and
youtube this is how you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna leave people's names out of it
but there's a very prominent podcast
that's like spiraling out of control and
failing with you know this he's like the
host is sitting in the room i'm like but
i won't point fingers no no no no no no
it's it's a very it's a big podcast
i'm gonna leave their name out of it
because what they would do is they would
manipulate reddit to uh get youtube
traction and it worked
so you'd you like there are certain
things everyone knew reddit wanted and
it was very very easy to gamify the
reddit upvote and downvote system and so
people people who didn't know about this
like politicians and big companies
didn't know how to gamify reddit
so it was just savvy people who had been
on the internet figured out how to
exploit it to make themselves famous and
they did and there was this period where
if you were smart and you had the
ability you'd make it happen
now i agree with you we're at a point
where it's you can't do it the latter's
being pulled up behind everybody if
you're really good you can find a way
but i i will say we're at a point where
the ladder's gone go on rumble well but
here's here's the fundamental issue and
this is what's so insane to me of how
this is backfiring because i feel like i
just squeezed in in the last second it
was like the last ditch effort and one
of the other people that squeezed in
sydney squeezed in john doyle squeezed
in this 2018 year this is right before
it got really bad in 2019 if you got in
on 2018 you essentially you know in the
terms of the girl getting passed around
the team you were the fourth or fifth in
but you still made it into into the game
into the party it's true you still got
something and we got action and a lot of
our channels aren't as big as other
channels we face a lot of stuff but i'm
grateful and i'm grateful for what i
have i'm grateful for the career god
gave me and i'm happy about that but
here's where i'm not happy
i'm upset and it makes me angry because
they have done
two things that is both unforgivable and
is going to damage our country as a
whole
and i don't think it can be undone
number one by shutting the door to
individual creators that was their point
is to take away independent media
because not just the right wing but as
we see with like russell brand or joe
rogan people who are not right wing but
are inherently open to ideas which is
now becoming a right-wing idea i don't
know if you saw today that uh msnbc says
that
exercise is a right-wing idea which i
actually kind of agree with but i will
say that they shut the door because uh
it's a joke but okay anyway so so they
shut up they shut the door to
independent and small media and that was
always their their plan my my new pa um
uh josiah moody who started he was like
hey i was like yeah tucker at his peak
we'll get you know three 3.5 million
views he goes yeah but have you seen his
youtube it's crushing and i go yeah bro
you i'm going to tell you about this one
thing called authoritative news sources
where they you know gave all the all the
news media
basically all of the views that we would
all get so number one that shut it out
and that doesn't allow us to have ideas
it gives the uh mainstream media control
of the internet which they didn't have
in our country but the worst part about
this is and you'll know this the worst
part about this
let's say you're new and you want to
come up well the way that you want to
come up in your new and your political
you can't go with the views model unless
you work for mainstream media so you've
got to build a cult following a cult
following will always reward more
extreme ideas and not only will it
reward more extreme ideas but it'll
actually push you into corners into more
niche avenues which will make somebody
try to appeal to a more extreme
perspective and i see this happening all
across the board especially with gen z
is that they've become very
authoritarian
on left and the right the people that
they like to watch that are more like
you know demonetized ban on twitch
either they're pushing straight up
fascism or communism they're pushing
absolute authoritarianism and what you
do is the only place that you can grow
you can go on to like you can go on to
any of these uh you know site apps where
people have fundamentally more extreme
views now what that does is it means if
you want to find someone who's young who
thinks like you who's a new creator tim
paul sucks elijah sucks sav sucks ian
sucks okay i don't hear these millennial
people whatever get the hell out where's
my gen z you've got a few options and
i'm not going to name them on the screen
you've got a few options i'm telling you
you're not getting kosher ideas those
are fringe ideas some of them you know
whether you agree with them or not you
have one option so they're creating an
extremist pipeline that they say they're
trying to ban and that's what makes it
sad is a young guy goes well i want to
be a right-wing podcaster if you're
espousing charlie kirk's views ben
shapiro's views you aren't going to get
anywhere you're going to have to go as
far right or as far left as possible
you're going to have to appeal to the
extreme base focus on small donations
and then we start breeding these little
like cosmic groups of people who are in
an echo chamber and they all think
they're right they're completely
detached from any of the mainstream
narrative any of the independent media
and they're doing their own thing and i
feel like we've lost them they hate us
all by the way gen z hates like they
really genuinely do like hate the
millennials and all the other creators
they're like very but they're right to
hate millennials well yeah but i'm what
i'm saying is i'm only half kidding but
i meant there's no olive branch because
you don't have like a good gen z
youtuber that comes on your show and
then you're debating and you're on his
channel we just don't have that there's
like a cut off it's like 25 years old
and everyone under that is now in their
own niche and we have a divide
politically and i don't know what
they're up to until i go to their their
their streaming sites and i'll watch
them and i'm like
oh crap
like i mean from charlie kirk to now i'm
glad we've gotten more like open to
discussing ideas charlie kirk is gen z
isn't he no he's my age 28 so he's
millennial 28 millennial yeah for sure i
think 27 6 is the cutoff for 25 is the
cutoff oh okay but but i was going to
say yeah under 25 i'm going i'm not it's
not that all their ideas are wrong i'm
just going oh we went here that quickly
it's been four years and we're now
talking about the authoritarian takeover
of the country and getting rid of the
constitution installing a king and like
i'm just an amano you know you know
religious state i'm going how did we
jump in five years from hey let's talk
about h-1b visas and talk about you know
immigration moratoriums to a catholic
christian dumb it's not that these
people are any i'm not scared of them or
anything i was going oh crap that was a
fast acceleration
politically i just want to mention
something you know because i was
watching i think i was watching fox i'm
not sure and a commercial came on with
charlie kirk
he was promoting some kind of product
for like uh back pain i think it was i'm
not entirely sure but it was just
interesting because it was like him
talking about how he was having struck
trouble exercising and he needed some
supplements or something like that and
i'm like isn't charlie like in his mid
to late 20s
it was just kind of weird i just you
know i don't know if you've seen the
commercials no i do know i always get
shocked that he's he's my age because
he's a lot richer than me intense so
much more this life people criticize him
but i always say this he has a lot you
could criticize and that shows he's done
a lot and there's fair points but all i
want to end with the point on that is
that that is where there's an article
written about me recently that was
supposed to be a pejorative like sort of
dis that was going oh elijah is becoming
the olive branch connecting the fringe
right to the mainstream right i'm like
hell yeah i am yes yes i am because i
think that the mainstream right freaking
sucks and i think the fringe right is
idealistic and they see the problems but
they're over correcting i think instead
of you know understanding that yeah
maybe you don't like feminist women and
maybe you know you want to see women be
wholesome you don't just hate women
don't be proud to be an incel the two
shall become one get married find a
wholesome woman you know if you're out
there and you're like hey yeah i realize
the lgbt movement sucks they're talking
about putting the gays against the wall
and shooting them and you're like hey
there's steps between that to where you
can fix society that doesn't have to
jump straight to like mass killings of
people and i see that i kind of think
maybe that's just a really fringe thing
because it is not as fringe as you would
think
it is the the idea of going from just
hey let's fight the lgbtq movement to
let to do away with them is pretty
pretty relevant and common and what i'm
saying is i'm going hey we need to kind
of slow this down for a second and we
need to figure this out because we're
going literally from like hey we need
christ back in the country which we do
to like let's create a religious state
that is we're going back yeah to a
monarchy and stuff and i'm going hey
that's maybe ideal and not realistic so
let's bring some of these kids out of
the out of the echo chambers let them
experience life and see hey let's let's
attain to some real solutions rather
than these extreme positions but these
might lead to absolute anarchy are these
positions like on tick-tock
they're on tick-tock they're on uh
they're on rumble they're on [ __ ] shoot
they are on independent streaming sites
and i'm not saying that i disagree with
everything these people think i just see
that they're young people who are
disconnected from older people with
wisdom so they're taking these super
over corrective world views that are
based in truth and out of a desire to
correct what's wrong in the country but
they're disconnected from reality
completely insane yeah but they're
disconnected from reality but their echo
chambers are growing so large that they
all think that they're right because
they don't like us they don't talk to
any of us they we don't talk no one will
talk to them people won't we won't even
say nick fuentes his name or any other
young gen z leader
and so like like so
we've got a corner like you're talking
about a very extreme statement here
about you know killing people i've not
seen
prominent or large groups of gen z doing
anything like that prominent and then
famous
i'm talking about prominent in terms of
something that's received a lot of
attention
like
it sounds maybe like yeah there are
fringe groups of people but they're not
very large i'm i'm i find it hard to
believe that there's large groups of gen
z who believe what you're saying
i would disagree and i would say that
we've i think it's our fault that's what
i'm saying i think we've rejected them
like people won't have conversations
with people and i think if you were very
neoliberal now and we've gotten to a
point where we've accepted a sort of
degenerate states of america and if you
start to disagree with that as you know
even if you like misgender someone you
could be banned these people reject it
entirely and they're just like let's
have a solution let's figure this out
and let's do something and i'm saying
very very extreme ideas don't get
rebuttaled i don't see like to your
point i don't see them getting
rebuttaled in these circles that it's
kind of like i agree with them there's a
big problem
but then it's like the two factors cut
them off and so did we this is what uh
bill ottman and daryl davis have been
talking about that minds the platform
has has been working on this for several
years
banning people doesn't stop their ideas
it makes them worse worse it puts them
in a small room where they can only
fester amongst themselves
so mines has been trying to find a way
to de-radicalize not to de-platform so
you know i think it was it was that
westboro baptist church woman yeah she
got de-radicalized on twitter the
daughter yeah yeah because she was
exposed to a bunch of other people and
other ideas and allowed her to realize
you know her ideas were wrong
if these big tech companies are are
taking people and isolating them
i mean yeah there are probably places
where people are saying really insane
things but i also find it strange like i
i i honestly i just i can't believe the
degree to which you've explained it
because i mean that's the kind of stuff
that gets banned for even being hinted
at like that's my point though we don't
like you look at where we're at as a
society as well that's what i was going
to say is all of the people who have
been banned off of twitter and all of
these other social media platforms the
people who have been watching the media
lied to us consistently for years
they've gotten radicalized themselves
and they don't feel like they can trust
anything in society they don't feel like
they can trust the government big tech
silences them and then they're going to
these platforms like parlor and gab and
you know all of these other places and
it's a huge echo chamber and so we're
seeing the radicalization of both the
right and the left like elijah's talking
about because we just have these echo
chambers with people reiterating these
same exact ideas and they continue to
get more and more extreme because
there's no debate or rebuttal like you
know in the early days of youtube i be
started to get very radical because what
you were talking about you the more
radical you get the larger your cult
following builds faster and i was like
propelling it and i went semi-crazy i
almost killed myself and i stopped
making videos i started building minds
behind the scenes intentionally or like
no like i was just so depressed with the
world and what was happening and i was
overly red pilled i guess i overdosed
and um
i find now i'm way more resilient to
being radicalized because i once was i
have this i understand how it happens i
went through it once before and i can i
can see it happening also watching it
happen to myself on video when i go back
and watch my videos helps a lot because
i see myself as a per i don't have to
see it from my own perspective i can see
it from an outside perspective and watch
myself go crazy and more people should
do that let themselves be seen in public
i know it's risky and it's it's
nerve-wracking but it's worth it this is
what's been happening since uh since
censorship became an issue the right is
overly policed
so the only people left standing are
suit wearing you know more moderate or
slightly center right conservative types
the left is left you know unabated so
the worst of the worst shine through the
way i described it before is like
imagine there are two kids
and the parent doesn't let
their once their son have any ice cream
but their daughter is allowed to have
all the ice cream they want
so you walk up and you see two kids and
you've got the daughter covered in
chocolate and fudge all over her face
and she looks like a disaster and you're
like that kid is unkempt messy and
disorganized something's wrong with it
and then you look over and you see this
clean cut looking you know child wearing
a nice little suit and you're like see
that's how you should do it the
assumption is one kid is inherently
better than the other but the reality is
the parent just doesn't let one kid
anywhere near ice cream so what happens
on social media is you can have a fringe
right wing conspiracy theorist go on the
platform and they get nuked in two
seconds you can have antifa advocate for
violence and they're allowed so what the
left is what ends up happening to
regular uh you know your your more
mainstream urban liberal types your city
urban liberal types is the prominent
voices that get played are extreme and
uncensored they say crazy things and
they're allowed so what happens when
richard spencer got punched in the face
the entirety of the establishment left
was cheering calling for violence and
celebrating it when the covington kid
situation happened you had large
quantities of blue check establishment
personalities and journalists advocating
for violence against these kids the
right can go nowhere near that so you
typically don't see the right calling
for violence on twitter granted i think
if the right was uncensored as well
you'd probably see similar things but
they get purged from the platform it
gives the right a more clean cut
appearance so
what they're effectively doing is the
left is continually radicalizing itself
through their own privilege and control
of institutions i think that will lead
to their downfall because regular people
who don't want to be involved in this
are starting more and more to align with
conservatives we see it in basically
every poll is the economy doing well
independent and republicans agree it's
not democrats for some reason think it
is do you approve of joe bro joe biden
independents and conservatives are like
no way he's doing a bad job democrats
are out there in wally world believing
their own cult nonsense
because of this regular middle of the
road people the people republicans need
in order to get elected they're siding
with republicans now the general pal the
general uh ballot polling for the
midterms shows republicans with a major
advantage in 538 about two and a half
points and real clear politics is like
three and a half points when democrats
have five points or less they lose seats
if republicans now have an advantage i
mean some are speculating it's going to
be massive in november for republicans
not that i think the republicans will do
anything but you know people are
certainly pissed off
you know what real fast just to say to
your point there's it's so common
actually that the fbi had to add the
phrase in minecraft to their list of uh
of dog whistles because there was so
much talk about violence and adding
additives to them that's increased so
heavily that the fbi even got involved
and i'm not even saying that you know
sometimes in wars are necessary there
are righteous wars but what i what i
what i want to thank you for for sharing
that that story is like people don't
realize that i myself too started out
extremely radical nearly cult-like like
into the terms of like when i where i
started was like you know fema camps and
alex alex jones got me started in
politics and then i switched over to
like ben shapiro and stuff and that
people were nervous about my political
beliefs i was getting in trouble i was
doing activism i you know early on had
obama's a communist t-shirt got banned
from political statements at school um
i'm not gonna explain everything i did
but i end up getting suspended for some
of my activism in high school and i
overcorrected and i started you know
doing the more the prageru
charlie kirk stuff you know big tent
let's all just get along i'm tired of
the animosity and it was just super
super cringy like i when i look back at
myself now i'm like i don't even
recognize the person i was i sort of
over corrected like you said because it
was like i got so scared i was like dude
the world the world's coming to an end
like i'm gonna freaking die and so the
point is is like i think sometimes when
you go through that moment to where you
you did find yourself in what would be
considered an extremist if i shared some
of the views i held then
i would i could be kicked off the i
would be kicked off the internet where
it is now and then i overcorrected the
point where i was like too cringed for
the internet and i look at some of my
old things i've made i'm like
wow that guy sucks like you're such a
loser in such a weak position you need
to get stronger and so starting from
that over correction now i can see like
i get why people do follow and believe
these radical things but i also think we
need to keep them based in reality and i
also get nervous too because a lot of
these are religiously motivated
arguments but neglect to bring the bible
and actually god's character into
account so these are people i talk to a
lot of these people who are who are very
zealous and religious and i respect that
but they don't know their bible it comes
a lot of times from a place of
self-righteousness and bitterness and
anger and hatred for the world that
they've been given and i i love the fact
that they want to change the world but i
do fear because i've been seeing it
across the board with gen z we're not
the popular ones they're not flooding
into our shows they're flooding into
those shows and if you look at their
conferences and what's going on they're
getting bigger bigger and bigger and
that's that's our fault if we're not
extending and trying to bridge the gap
and we just blame tech companies and go
well i guess life is like this and we're
just on the outskirts it's like no i
believe in america we can bridge this
intellectual gap that we're having
dude a few years ago ben shapiro was
considered the intellectual dark web and
now people think ben shapiro is like the
softest dude ever on on major social
issues and that was what in like since
2016 intellectual dark web was was was
progressives no but it was the only
concern but that's what i'm saying he
was considered to be like controversial
and it's like ben shapiro's not
controversial at all
like he's probably one of those kosher
people i'm i'm saying i see a problem we
haven't
viewers no yes so do i 25 of my my
audience are about 22 that's not what i
meant overall there are gen z that's
where they're gravitating so people are
but it's not like all gen z is going in
our direction i see the shift turning
into more extreme like i think it's
because two gen z is living through the
most insane period our country has seen
in a long time again look at what's
going on with the supreme court nominee
right now she can't even identify what a
woman is and then uses the word
immediately after they're living through
this insane time of cancer culture
so we have this entire subset of the
generation that feels so ostracized
feels so radicalized and then they see
the conservative movement that is
supposed to stand for them and it's
people like i said matt schlapp who are
big tent conservatives and they don't
draw any hard lines which is why
conservatism as a whole is just
liberalism at this point
and that's even my beef with
libertarianism if you look at human
psychology people do
at their core inherently need to be led
like not everybody is a leader some
people are followers and if you don't
have somebody in the conservative
movement that's actually leading the
movement in the way that it should be
led and it's actually standing up for
these conservative values look at where
we're at right now that's why we have
two factions of conservatives and that's
why gen z feels so unheard because they
think that conservatives are empathetic
because they are because we're you know
promoting people like caitlyn jenner
we're promoting people who do not stand
for traditional conservatism and they
see that
um well hey guys everyone's looking at
me
i i find that the solution lies in the
systems that we create we've been
working with the chair we're building a
charity that is building decentralized
software where you can host your own
content on a server of your choice or
your own server and get direct
subscriptions uh it's you still have to
worry about verizon shutting you down
your isp shutting you down yeah um maybe
verizon is the isp but
there's also a mesh networking app
called briar where you can actually
download the app and text people offline
with bluetooth so we're building up the
mesh network cruise it once briar
awesome not specifically there's another
app that did just that and it was the
craziest thing they told everyone turn
your bluetooth on and then everyone's
phone acts like a cell tower so you
could message your friend and your your
message is encrypted and it bounced off
of everyone's it bounces everyone's
phone everyone's phone gets it but only
the one with the key would actually see
the message you can use it in a war if
all the power goes out for instance
i'm coming here in a war oh dude it's
going to be something i mean you can't
play badminton uh bro the reason i bring
it up oh is because i do believe that
there needs to be more leaders and but
that not like people like elon musk he
doesn't come out and tell everyone hey
i'm your leader now he just makes great
technology and because of that we look
at him like a sort of leader so i want
to be kind of like i'm trying to do that
right yeah that's what people need let's
do this let's do one more quick segment
let's talk about war because we got it
the new york times ran this story the
smaller bombs that could turn ukraine
into a nuclear war zone a photo released
by russian state-owned news agency
showing the iskinder m launch vehicle
being loaded with a ballistic missile
during military exercises at a russian
firing range in the uh how do you
pronounce that
you sur
usuriask
in 2016.
now this is this is great in destructive
power the hemis of the cold war dwarfed
the american atomic bomb that destroyed
hiroshima washington's biggest test
blast was one thousand times as large
moscow's was three thousand times on
both sides the idea was to turn strikes
with threats of vast retaliation with
mutual assured destruction or mad the
psychological bar was so high that
nuclear strikes came to be seen as
unthinkable today both the russia russia
and the us have nuclear arms that are
much less destructive their power just
fractions of the hiroshima's bomb's
force their use perhaps less frightening
and more thinkable so this is what i was
talking about a few weeks ago when i
said nuclear war can it seems to me to
be uh possible
and um but tim it's okay maybe it's good
for the environment remember
they came out and said that it's good
for the environment well that was 10
years ago i think usa today had read an
op-ed saying a small nuclear war could
be good for the environment
so what i'm what i'm saying is we might
see nuclear artillery we're going to see
russia will use in my opinion if they
need to if they are losing i would mean
i would not be surprised if russia does
use nukes i don't know let me make sure
i'm clarifying this i don't know if the
probability that russia just uses this
is ten percent or two percent fifty
percent or one percent but vladimir
putin continually threatens to use nukes
as he will not back down there are a lot
of people who fear that uh nato doesn't
care they're reckless or biden is
completely inept and what we'll end up
seeing is russia they keep reporting is
being backed into a corner i don't
completely believe that i think it would
be absurd to think ukraine could beat
russia russia's a massive power even if
it's not as big as nato it's like half
as big as nato but if russia gets
pressed uh if russia gets pressed by
nato they may say okay let's land the
big guns gravity bombs maybe something
not as big as hiroshima or nagasaki but
powerful bombs they're already using the
thermobaric bombs these things are crazy
the missile comes out comes down ejects
fuel spraying it all through the air and
then sucks all the air up and explodes
like just vaporizing people so they've
already got very very powerful but lower
yield weapons if putin had to i think he
would use it if nato intervenes i think
it's possible he does and then i'm
worried about what happens to europe
will we will we actually see russia say
you're not going to nuke us back we can
do what we want and then uh you know
honestly i was thinking about it earlier
because there's a conspiracy theory
someone predicted a year ago what's
happening now and so this this meme's
going viral where some guy's like here's
going to happen with russia and the next
step they said was that nato would get
involved russia would threaten nuclear
weapons nato would call their bluff
russia would say ho yeah and then fire a
nuke and then you get nuclear war i'm
not entirely like it seems far-fetched
but i also think it would be silly for
us at this point it would be uh it would
be optimism and normalcy bias to think a
nuclear war would never happen you i
think specifically you're talking about
explosive nuclear weapons too because uh
the americans in iraq and the second
iraq war use depleted uranium weapons
because in order to penetrate armor in a
tank that's made with the depleted
uranium you need depleted uranium
bullets so they just sprayed them across
the desert they're underground in the
desert irradiating the land yeah we're
talking about nuclear war so not all
nuclear weapons have have a radio
radioactive yield
uh that's intentional so some of them
actually don't some of them are just
concussive shockwaves or explosive but
yeah i mean you know what are your
thoughts do you think
where do you think this goes and and
what would you do see all i would say to
that is what what's to deter russia from
using nuclear weapons to keep that they
want to keep their country intact and
they want to keep ukraine intact but do
you really think that russia hears the
u.s does russia fear nato does russia
fear anyone right now i mean we right
now we were you know under donald trump
and even trump came out and said this
russia didn't act this way putin didn't
act this way when trump was in office
because trump was a respected leader
whether or not the left wants to say
that or not like he was you know off the
cuff no one ever knew what was going to
happen with him look what happened with
uh solemnani and iran when they messed
with america donald trump you know
brought down the hammer look at russia
right now they're not fearful of
anything they're not fearful of
retaliation because we're not a
superpower anymore i really you know
would venture to say that and again with
the whole nato situation i'm not a
geopolitical expert so you know inform
me on this point but like what is really
to stop russia from doing this well we
the u.s is a superpower the issue
anymore
is that thucydides trap looms
and uh there's a there's a one of the
one of these there's a conspiracy theory
that western powers for the past 20
years have known through cities trap is
a real possibility and as we've already
shown all of you the liberal world order
exists the council on foreign relations
explains this and they say there will be
a new world order one of the theories is
that
the powerful elites of the council on
foreign relations the trilateral
trilateral commission etc i mean these
are organizations that outright just say
they're doing these things and you can
call it a conspiracy i don't know
whatever maybe they're lying but cfr is
newsguard certified they say there's a
liberal world order
now these people have to be aware of
thucydides trap that u.s is growing us
is is a large economic power the largest
and china is growing as an economic
power and that means world war three is
likely if your intention is to prevent
world war iii then you need to stop the
city's trap from happening well you
can't stop china from growing so what do
you do you cut off a tall grass in the
u.s you [ __ ] the united states so
that they fall as fast as china rises
and thus you avoid a war i'm not saying
that's true but i'm saying it's
certainly you know one theory about the
policies enacted by the binding
administration and the obama
administration that have seemingly hurt
the united states and not even them i
mean george w bush and bill clinton as
well yeah well i don't even believe the
narrative that the the nuclear war is
going to happen i i think it's always
possible right there's always
everything's possible ian might give me
a million dollars so possibly it is
possible we never actually know uh but
ultimately speaking i think this is to
stoke the fear with this idea if there
was going to be a real nuclear attack i
don't think the media would actually be
discussing this i think we'd be in
preparation mode and something would be
announced with like a genuine
understanding hey
this is like like how they did with
russia how they go
they're going to invade on this day like
this is what's going to happen and no
one heard about this until russia was
going to invade now of course i joked
about it that week ago that was the zero
day war because they kept getting it
wrong and if you leave it to the bite
administration to literally
be stupid enough to like announce the
exact day that he knows he's going to
invade as if you know he's going to be
like okay i'll go ahead and keep to the
date so we don't change our dinner plans
um but you know he ended up invading he
ended up going inside and and going uh
you know first the peacekeeping mission
and then moving forward but
ultimately everything i hear is about
creating hatred not just for russia but
for russians and the hatred for russians
is why i don't believe the nuclear side
because anything they can use to get
people to distance themselves and
recreate an iron curtain an iron wall
between that nation seems to be at hand
and there's one thing i know not
everyone cares about anything but
everybody knows nuclear war especially
boomers and people who grew up you know
and how to do the drills underneath
their desks they're aware of this
they've been around around the bush here
and they don't want that and nobody
wants that and that's why i think they
start to say like small nuclear warheads
because the chances of russia like they
know it's ludicrous letting off these
you know megaton warheads this is not
going to happen so they have to shrink
the threat this is the first time i've
ever heard in history and i might be
wrong where we're talking about you know
oh micro warheads and we're back to
micro penises and micro
everything's shrinking backwards we've
been talking about this for a few weeks
no no that's not what i meant i meant
like not this story today i i've heard
this this argument i meant now it's like
where they have to kind of change the
threat from something that we've never
had this global discussion on micro
warheads to like this might happen and i
always feel like with the ghost of kiev
snake island the video that came out
today that you mentioned on twitter it's
been nothing but propaganda
to the point that i just put pictures up
for my trip in ukraine and people needed
to debunk them like i'm sitting here
right now fast flight but the nuclear
war angle is actually preventing nato
from intervening
but i but i don't know but but i don't i
don't think so though because i i think
that putin is pretty if you watch what
his speeches are not that i would
believe everything he says he's kind of
upfront about what he wants and i think
the issue even if you go back to noam
chomsky trying to explain what's been
happening inside of ukraine he's not
okay with it being militarized he does
not want it armed he wants a neutral
position between nato and russia he
knows these are two different worlds
could putin do anything anyone could
because we on a different idea for for
our society for our life it's a whole
new movement he cares about why why does
he want ukraine to be neutral because
that's right that's right at his border
he's always estonia and latvia yeah but
i think ukraine actually has i believe
they're more corrupted in terms of with
our own regime and government it's a
puppet arm of the united states estonia
and latvia are nato members
yes but i'm saying i think ukraine
specifically like as we're seeing now i
don't know if we're gonna donate like
with georgia i don't think we're gonna
do i don't know if we're gonna really
donate arms and really fight as hard as
you would think but ukraine sits as a
middle puppet that we control that we
don't control but it's still for money
it's a u.s proxy it is in my opinion
nothing to do with neutrality vladimir
putin wants access to their only warm
water port in crimea and if ukraine goes
eu they cut russia off
so russia moves in through the east they
go they go into the country they're
effectively trying to bifurcate from the
north and the south
ultimately i don't know where where
putin goes to this neutrality is i
believe part of his goal i think it's a
lot to do with him wanting to maximize
um
energy sales into europe which is what
you know essentially helps fund the the
russian economy but i think crimea
there's a reason he took it instantly
russia has one warm water port in the
black sea one warm water port it's in
the black sea it's crimea and they need
more than just you know going south
through crimea they need the the land
bridge to the north that i think is why
putin is doing it
he doesn't care about estonia and latvia
sure because he doesn't have anything
there he has kaliningrad he has access
to the baltic sea already so he doesn't
care about these other states
i mean it's an onion i think it's
multifaceted and i think if you've seen
this all we've heard about ukraine in
the last few years has been american
corruption money laundering elitist
families and even trump you saw that i
mean back that old clip where he's
literally sitting with zielinski saying
this is a very corrupt country that
deals with massive layers of corruption
meaning we've known this is a problem
state and putin's been aware of this too
but i'm just saying when me when noah
chomsky and me are agreeing there's
something's very wrong in the world in
general saying in warning just in 2018
hey
the media has been deceiving the
ukrainian people western media into
thinking they can be a western nation
but it has been understood with
gorbachev on that any sort of push to
move western in ukraine would end in a
bloody war and would end in some sort of
you know uh aggression from the russian
government no matter what leader was in
power he was saying they're not going to
accept that and they're going to invade
so i'm just saying that you know they've
been duped just like we're standing with
ukraine i think the ukrainians don't
realize that the the proxy that they
have and the importance of that position
i believe the west pushed this invasion
to be necessary i don't think if we
hadn't if we had pulled out not
installed our own regime not created a
revolution through social media i don't
think this would have happened now but i
do believe that because of the inability
for the west and the east to somehow
leave some country alone we can't leave
anybody alone this was going to happen
you want to know there's a simple reason
why ukrainians favor the eu and you know
what it is what holiday more
yeah that's that's that's really the big
so
it's a really horrifying story when i
yeah so uh russia wants to expand its
power they want the russian trade
federation the eu obviously wants to
expand wants the bread basket of europe
when i went to ukraine and talked to a
lot of people they all said we have the
opportunity to either join with russia
and have this trade federation which
would benefit us greatly or the eu which
would be you know very similar and then
a lot of people were like we don't trust
russia because they genocided our people
yeah the holdemore a man-made famine a
man-made famine convulsed the soviet
republic of ukraine from 1932 to 33. how
many people died how many people starved
to death like tens
yeah because because uh the soviets
had disdain for the ukrainians as a
people
and wanted to
make but then in world war ii
technically still they gave a lot of
their own life 3.9 million kiev i mean
or to like sort of to fight in ukraine
soviets i mean it wasn't there's quite a
bit of troops soviets executed all the
intellectuals in eastern europe took
over the communists were just like a a
malignancy of evil but russian history
goes way before the so the soviets i'm
just saying like that's obviously a
period but i'm not defending the soviet
time but i'm saying this idea of a
russian federation
of the russian people i i do believe
there is some shared understanding and
value i mean it's not too long ago with
with i'm talking about my opinion on
russia i'm saying yeah the ukrainians i
spoke with said we don't trust the
russians we know it happened 20 years
ago i mean what year was the holy number
was like late 32 33 i wouldn't trust
between 31 and 34.
and then you had just the soviet union
uh going until uh you know only 20 or 30
years ago so these people are like nah
not interested
you know they're like we'll take the
capitalists in europe for all their
faults
so yeah but i'm saying i think the media
brainwashed them into thinking that
could happen like that's my whole point
is that i like our media you know tells
us things that are absolutely false that
there was you know we were safe in in
afghanistan that it was going to be a
smooth pull out and it wasn't a smooth
pull out it was literally like a you
know end of prom night sloppy it was a
surrender a literal military survivor
and they said it wasn't like vietnam but
it was i'm saying i do believe that our
media that the influence by nato in the
west has tricked them into thinking that
they could be a part of the west without
a war and i'm not blaming them do
whatever the hell you want with your own
country you know the russians fine but
just so you know if you want this you're
going to have the situation on your hand
with 10 million refugees and that's i'm
not blaming the people for getting duped
i'm saying i believe that this was if
this continued the way it did as we're
seeing it was going to be unavoidable
because russia wasn't going to put up
with it even if it's for whatever reason
you said or things that we don't know
because i'm not an expert despite the
joke that i'm an eastern european war
expert because everyone is now right um
if i put a russia and a ukraine flag in
my bio so now i know i'm i i'm an expert
solidarity yeah uh i i just got to say i
think we'll find out the real point of
this as time goes on and if he's going
to push forward
no crap i mean i'm not going to accept
that i wouldn't accept russia pushing
further into europe and i don't think
any european country should and i hope
we don't ever get there let's go to
super chats if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show if you really
like it and go to timcast.com become a
member we're going to have a very spicy
members only show i can just tell and
you're going to love it so that will be
over at timcast.com around 11 or so pm
sign up help help us out and let's read
some of these super chats make 1984
fiction again says elijah you cannot
claim to be against authoritarianism and
grow an undeniable symbol of authority
under your nose like that
oh thank you
i'm not fully against authoritarianism
and i thought the mustache was gorgeous
yeah yeah mustache march is turning it's
going to go into uh mustache
it's not the worst when you think of
liberty and authority what how do you
balance those out on the variance scale
percentage if you start seeing the
mustache shrinking towards the middle
you should get worried are you okay with
like 23 percent authority 70
67 was it 77. i started obsession with
the roman salute and stuff yeah call me
all right let's see ham rod says tim
regarding my dan crenshaw chat yesterday
an audio came out of dan saying he's not
establishment but you two youtubers are
also thanks for having elijah on uh did
you hear about that dan crenshaw saying
youtubers were establishment or
something i heard that
damn yeah he said what are they
crunching answers conservative
influencers were grifters
did he actually say grifter i don't know
if he said
that's essentially what he was saying is
that they are uh how do you really feel
about dan crenshaw love dan crenshaw we
absolutely love him we have that
actually we don't have a barbie doll in
more or memory of dan crenshaw we have
madison catherine though yeah we do we
have a madison cotton barbie yeah we do
huh all right
i don't know freddie gorman freda gorman
says tim would you be interested in
speaking with the most prominent russian
libertarian mikhail svetov you can reach
him on twitter at msuvitov
he is a former chairman of a russian
libertarian party and organized one of
the biggest protests in russian history
interesting we'll take a look we'll look
into it
yep
tom mihawk says read your comments about
star trek versus wars the politics and
the prequels is actually pretty
interesting alex jones did a video on it
where he talks about the conspiracy the
elites employed to start a civil war and
gain power yeah that's true i do like
that the uh the prequel politics
although i don't think the movies were
particularly well made i just think star
trek has a large swath of really great
philosophical moral ethical content
that's a it's very interesting
good stuff
eric cecil says reddit got two
battalions of the ukrainian foreign
legion killed by sharing their location
via metadata on their posts i don't
think a lot of people are thinking about
this decision because of media
lionization but i hope they get a lot of
upvotes
so yeah that was one of the stories we
didn't get to it's a viral post on
reddit where
people were celebrating like hey we're
here with you know we're volunteering
for ukraine we're a bunch of untrained
random people who came here and the
russians who are sophisticated military
experts said we can easily identify
where this building is and then they
blew it up
that's the problem with what social
media people trying to go to ukraine for
clout and get clicks on a photo i'm
getting nervous now like three days
before you were leaving you kept putting
up pictures in the studio slightly
offensive studio yeah with like geo tags
and i'm like you kept saying hey i'm
here
here's my exact thing he stands with
ukraine he stands with ukraine that was
very weird and now we know that's weird
cia says tim have you seen who's the new
president of earth in star trek
discovery i think you'll agree she's out
of this world is that stacey abrams yeah
yeah star trek discoveries and star trek
it's fan fiction the first president to
also have their own gravitational pull
oh yeah they orbit planets and moons
orbit them correct stacey abrams
ross says tim i feel your view about no
shadowy cabal to control everything is
naive biden is doing the bidding of his
masters in the federal reserve privately
and foreign investors owned they funded
lenin this is business as usual so what
i was saying when biden said there you
know we created a liberal world order
and then every three to four generations
there's like a you know a big event and
60 million people died and and then he
was like there will be a new world order
it's funny because he's like referencing
the fourth turning so uh
my point was
what happened to the world economic
forum i think people assume there's like
a big grand table where they all sit
around and joe biden's like all right
masters tell me what to do that's not
what happens
they they these people have meetings
they have shared goals it's easier like
the problem with a lot of people's view
of these things that there's like an
organization to it is that
that actually in my opinion gives them
more credit than they deserve and it
actually is less scary the scarier thing
is that there is an ideological there's
a sphere of influence of powerful elites
who get together and they pull people in
and some people pop out but this sphere
this hive the swarm exists that's when
you guys were talking about super powers
earlier and who is it is it china or the
u.s but i think it's like the swift
payment system and the bank of
international settlements the federal
reserve sold us out man and that thing
if it wants to shut your country off
from your economy that's the one of the
greatest powers you have on earth but so
so so it's essentially
a rich person can enter the sphere of
influence and it's not like anyone tells
them what to do you know bezos or bill
gates certainly people came before them
right it's that you you reach this level
and then you get invited to these
meetings where you sit down and they say
what do you think you've got this big
company and then everyone talks and
ultimately they all align themselves
cooperatively not authoritatively you
know what i mean isn't it kind of crazy
how bill gates and oprah winfrey and a
bunch of these billionaires were meeting
together talking about depopulation that
was a wall street journal article you
can look that up back in 2015 i believe
uh they were all they all got together
they were talking about these
populations
that's the point there's no boss of that
well i think they were talking about
slowing the population growth it's
different than actually depopulation
correct we'll say this though true
wealth is receiving a gift from ian
that's right this thing's heavy too i'm
going to request a roll from both of you
yeah you're holding up the hundred side
of things i don't even roll this very
slowly or you're just gonna keep rolling
every time i'm here i see something that
i didn't know existed
that's a great role i feel like they're
like dragon strikes grab that later
they're heavy i love them yeah they're
awesome all right let's read these super
chats we got one we got two server chats
i'm going to read and you'll like them
both uh
porkins holt says tim is 100 right
elijah forgot how to fight
robert dalvik silverstein silverstein
says elijah is right everybody who needs
the slim chance of making a life do not
dare question the branch they are
standing on so the second guy was right
good job man
well i'll give you another one brian
knoll says 100 with elijah your
arrogance tim is causing you to lack any
empathy for these girls you have to
remember these women are young they
don't have the life experience thank you
elijah well put
well i blame their parents i was going
to say tim one thing that we share in
common is that people tell us that we
don't shut up we don't let our guests
talk and we're arrogant so i'm glad to
know that we have the same haters
they're probably the same commenter like
they're at your show like buying a
comment on tim copy and paper and copy
and oh and they just changed tim with
elijah you know the issue with the
parents on this one is that they're all
in college
these kids these these grown adult women
are in college at this point so their
parents aren't involved anymore i mean
this is the craziest thing to me it's
like how old are they they're they're
they're adults they're in their 20s but
think about your mentality when you were
18 to 20. these are kids idiots
yeah i didn't know much at all that's
what i'm saying it's like you when
you're 18 to 22 like you're just taking
drugs
i that was you i guess
i was 23 when i started smoking
you smoke did you you spoke to the
college students about the penises and
the periods i watched you what did they
say because i i was i could not believe
what i was listening to this is who's in
college now no i mean i said the quote
earlier that what men can get periods
they can get pregnant women have penises
they were saying and i asked them i was
like so uh have you seen leah thomas
stand next to uh you know
her female athletes and competitors and
they're like no no we can't see a
biological difference they look exactly
like that i think it's very stark but
you know that's because it was a man
that transitioned into a woman and that
you know that stands just your opinion
it's not the fact that uh you know leah
thomas has brought shoulders into six
feet tall look man if that's one broad
female
if you if if you have one faction that
is willing to burn down cities and the
other faction is like tim don't get mad
at people who won't stand up for
themselves like i'm not surprised we are
kind of an award you're right when the
democrats accuse brett kavanaugh of
being party to gang rape on more than
one occasion and the best the right can
muster up is josh hawley saying i have
concerns about your lenient sentences
and he actually went on to say i do
believe judge uh uh katanji brown
jackson will have a coherent and
thoughtful response i believe she's
she's uh you will be able to well
explain this how do you see your first
name
that's how we've been saying it i don't
know but the point is
i tweeted this if the republicans were
as arrogant or i said as ruthless and
had the callousness and ruthlessness of
the democrats they'd be calling katanji
brown a pedophile but the republicans
are extremely weak at least relative to
democrats now you can say principled in
a sense that they don't want to you know
besmirch the decorum of the chamber and
they're trying to be fair and reasonable
but this is my point um when you have
you know i'm not asking these young
girls to throw away their careers but
i'm asking to take a small risk right so
some people have said okay tim but you
support youtube you're using the
platform you know they censor people and
i'm like yeah we've had steve bannon on
what three times four times
alex jones on four times we regularly
you know do everything we can to uh you
know these are people who are censored
we've brought them back to the platform
and we'll keep doing things like that
and then we set up timcast.com where we
can carry out other conversations and
then we advocate for things like rumble
so we're absolutely speaking up and
trying to push back while being a part
of this if these young women at the swim
meets were like hey we all kind of have
an issue with this we're going to swim
i'd be like right on
i respect that my issue is the only
person to speak up is the one who got
bumped like not even the person right
above her is like yeah that's not cool
she got bumped she won't even say
anything but she had an nda or something
that was my question to you um is that
i'm wondering if while they're in the
competition it would be interesting to
find out if there's certain rules on
like you know not making political
statements and or something like that
that's what they were told is that they
had to be silent
about leah thomas because it was such a
controversial issue which is why none of
them spoke out except for rose pouch who
is the uh athlete that i answered
because because i've been involved in an
organization before when i was in high
school and uh it was like a student
leadership type thing now of course it
was a very far left
progressive california group but it was
very keen on not like making political
statements and why i would find this
ironic with turning point like we're
non-profit we can't make political
statements like i can't get what you're
saying but you're a political group but
i know some people though
i know i'm saying that's a little
different but i'm wondering
if they're just thinking like hey yeah
like leah thomas can't make a political
statement i can't even the leah thomas
is a political statement like the
existence is a political statement i
think and you would even argue yeah them
swimming is a political statement that
they agree because they're not quitting
maybe they just don't understand what a
political statement is and they don't
realize that it's gonna take one to
speak to open up the floodgate or i'm
wrong and they all agree and they're
brainwashed like the rest of america
which sucks
all right here's another one poor
consult says tim is right y'all are
short-sighted and our kids will suffer
when we die imagine the founders if they
didn't fight because they'd lose it all
excuses
it's a it's it's a good debate i will be
i will be honest is it less than one
pers but didn't i i might be wrong with
this but in the in the revolution didn't
like one percent or less and i might see
like a total idiot right now like
actually fight in the war of the
population maybe it was more than that
but i was reading we don't actually know
some say it's three percent right so
what i was saying is is that that my
point wasn't that we don't need fighters
it's sad that we're in a point where we
expect not only everyone to fight but
like women too where like i wish the
fight against this was with male
administrators that were fighting for
what's going on the university and dads
and parents not like these girls who are
like hey you better not swim it's like
that's what it's gotten dead this far
you're like that sucks because
yeah all right so we got this from
zenthias who says if i stood up for what
i believed i would never work a day in
my life and no way would i be able to
provide for my fiance's immigration into
the usa
my response to that is
you care more about your fiance's
immigration than you do the values of
the united states
if that statement
offends you that says more about your
own values than mine because typically
when i tell people this they get really
mad so uh someone i told this before who
said i really want to do what you do i
want to travel the world and do
journalism and then i said well then go
do it the response to me was i can't
afford it and i was like you have a you
have a williamsburg apartment for like
several thousand dollars a month get rid
of the apartment sleep on couches and
you can do it and they said but i like
my apartment and i'm like then you like
your apartment more than traveling the
world and reporting on news and they got
really mad and they're like that's not
true i should have a right to live in a
nice apartment and travel and i'm like i
don't care about what you think your
rights are i'm pointing out you've got x
amount of cash you can choose to do one
of two things you've made your choice
showing where your priorities lie
so for zenthis i'm not issuing this as a
moral statement or a value statement i'm
saying you care more about your fiance
than you do about the usa and maybe
that's fine i don't know start poor and
single right so it's a hard place to
have but it is true i mean like i said
this is a war like whether or not we
want to admit it we are in a
psychological war if you will we have
two separate factions of america so what
tim is saying is right if people want to
enact real change they're going to have
to make big sacrifices and that means
losing your job you know telling your
fiance no for the next couple of years
but that's the reality of it but there
are softer ways and i do want to explain
this like i when i got into this career
i didn't quit my job my day job until a
year into this when i knew i could
support myself and i want to remind
people not on patreon that if you do
have dreams or you do want to do stuff
sometimes we feel like we're left with
two options like russia or ukraine
rather than saying well i don't really
stand with either i'm staying with the
people of both but not either sometimes
there is other options and there are
other ways around things so i always say
when you're stuck between this like
forced major of hey you gotta choose and
your life's gonna get ruined if you
don't do this ask yourself if there is a
way to ease into the values that you
want to appeal to or that you want to be
even if you're not ready now to like
lose your job well find out if you can
protest more at work and start with
something i'm saying start with
something to move yourself in the
direction so you don't live a
hypocritical life if you're not willing
to make that big of a jump
at least make a small step and start
making a strategic plan to getting to a
point to where maybe you start your own
business now so that you can quit the
job and that you finally will be able to
make the jump and i don't think there's
any wrong thing wrong with strategy
there was a band in the 90s and i was
reading the story the lead singer ended
up getting a job
at as a manager of a theater and it was
like this this article was like very
disparaging like wow how you know he was
this big famous musician and now what is
he doing
manager at a theater and that's a scary
story the way that society treats you if
you have this you know prominent
position and you lose it so i remember
when i was working for fusion i had an
abc news badge i was in the abc news
building i had access to go around i
would be goldbergs in the elevator i'd
walk out and there were people all there
are these gates and security guards and
no one could go anywhere near the doors
and they're always waiting trying to get
autographs and i'm like man look where i
am in this building one block from
central park
there's there's you know all of these
prominent abc personalities i was
getting paid hundreds of thousands of
thousands of dollars per year
and then i was like i can't do what they
want me to do and i don't want to be
here because they were like our audience
is young and progressive and that's what
we're gonna do and that's what we want
you to do and so i told the president we
had a meeting this was um i think we
were in vegas the time and i was like
break my contract i can't do this
anymore. and the scary thing to me was i
was like if i break this contract for
these reasons i'm not going to work in
new york media ever again it's done
these people have already started
claiming that i was racist because they
were all woke and i refused to play
their game they were they were uh
talking smack about me because i had
appeared on fox news after a trump
supporter got hit in the both bag of
rocks and i said i'd rather be a theater
manager than work in this industry and
after i left fusion
there was like five months of me
literally doing nothing i didn't know
what to do i'd wake up and then i would
do like some live streams here and there
i'd wake up and play destiny you know
the video game and then i thought to
myself as i pulled out of my savings i
was like man
i don't know what i can do i don't know
where i'm supposed to go from here
there's no there's no me getting a job
at any of these companies now they've
all lost their minds and i don't want to
work for them anyway i had i had
meetings with vox i had meetings with
buzzfeed and that was just like this is
before fusion and i was just like
there's no way i'm going to those
companies after everything that happened
at fusion so what am i going to do and i
was like man i might have to just leave
new york go back to the suburbs of
chicago and just work in consulting or
something and then i was like all right
well for the time being i'll start
working as hard as i can but it was
terrifying yeah it was scary and for the
first few months of doing youtube i was
negative and it cost me a large portion
of my savings and then i was like but
i'm gonna find a way to to to get
through this it took me a year to get
out of uh uh out of the red and into the
black and then once i got into the black
i was down probably tens of thousands of
dollars tim c i'm so happy you're
sharing this story because so many
people in our society today we live in
such an instant gratification society
they expect to get on youtube be famous
immediately make it they expect to go
out on the streets get that viral clip
get on tucker carlson right away and
when it doesn't happen they give up and
that's the difference between winners
and losers is that everybody is going to
fail at one point or another but the
winners continue to keep pushing forward
until they reach their goal so i'm so
glad you said that story because you
know it really shows the reality of this
industry of success as a whole it's hard
to get there it doesn't happen overnight
you will struggle you will have to
sacrifice your own savings account
financially mentally physically i've
seen it from everybody in this industry
people have to sacrifice so much but
once they achieve their goals everyone's
looking at them now and it's like well i
want to do that too why can't i do it i
met uh try harder the guitarist from
deathcad for cutie it's a band if you
guys haven't i don't know if you've
heard oh yeah and i asked him what was
the key to success he said just keep
playing music yeah because so many
people will you know you've got all
these bands around you when you're young
but one by one they all quit they give
up and then eventually before you
realize it you're just the band that's
left so people know who you are because
everyone else stopped and if people want
music it's like well you've been around
for a long time so people have heard of
you they come to your shows and then
before you realize it you're just the
last remaining band from your from your
generation or whatever from your group
and that was really it was like
perseverance it does it does work i want
to say this to to attest to your actual
living out your uh belief there
obviously you're making good money
working for alex jones a legend and then
you wanted to go out and report in order
to do so
you had to work for me
i know
so you you went so many steps down to
try to attain your your goal and i gotta
say this
living off of 37 a week in a pack of
trident gum you persisted you continued
and now you're independent and the super
uber famous journalist who's getting
with jordan peterson and everybody
and that just shows it you work really
hard but on the on the on the on the
real side though too um you know i think
that's what i was saying with the
calculatedness and i know your eagerness
to tim on this but i tell people like
genuinely even now this is why it's hard
for me to comment like there are
compromises i've made to stay on youtube
or to stay on sites that i could be more
honest or more truthful or say more that
i have thought that the trade-off for
having a stable income with my with my
family
is not worth it like just just so i can
right now on this you know on this uh
live stream call leah thomas that the
pronoun in your live stream i'm not
going to risk your livelihood so that i
can be right right i'm not going to do
that that's different your livelihood
but i'm also saying i i understand
that you got to be calculated because
i always talk about this too that i see
with the young people this is why isis
goes after the young men some people
think that bravery is just charging the
front lines in world war one there's no
reason to be cannon fodder there's no
reason to just sacrifice your life like
where some people were it's to be
actually calculated because i promised
this to people
the idea of like when i i've spoken to
people like well if i don't get
vaccinated then i'm going to get fired
and i go you're looking at this wrong
you're looking at this like you have two
choices the reality is is that like i
even asked someone did you think about
moving states did you think about moving
from a for-profit to a non-profit
hospital did you think about moving to a
religious institution where the
exemptions could work in a religious
hospital have you thought about
something like that where it won't work
but you could have a religious argument
here at this catholic place and i've
asked people do you know you could
change things and also reminder that you
could also like sometimes you can
actually work for a private firm which
is not medical be a consultant be remote
nurse doing zoom calls and whatnot or a
resume doctor and you can actually do
these kinds of things so i just meant
people calculate it you don't have to go
from being a a grifter or a martyr like
you don't have to just jump the gun
there is there is a middle ground so we
have timcast.com so every screen you
want to say we're going to say in you
know three minutes when we switch to the
tim cast website so i recognize
we get a lot of we get a lot of free
stuff from youtube that's what people
need to hear you get a lot of free stuff
from youtube they give us free
advertising i don't i've not paid for
any marketing for this show all organic
but that means youtube's algorithm or by
choice for some reason we've been we've
appeared and been suggested and then i
can use that to be like okay everybody
go to our website become members and
then we're going to have conversations
that these bigger platforms don't want
us to have that way the conversations
still happen we have steve bannon he can
say everything he wants we have you guys
here we're going to go nuts in the
members only show and that's the
platform we build and truth be told
we've been
uh it's it's way safer we're seeing now
with what uh dan bongino is doing with
parallel economy and rumble how they're
they're building up alternates and
that's what needs to happen
so
uh
i had a super chat
it's gone now no because sometimes it
jumps but the point somebody was making
is that it disappeared but it's tim's
really really really cool he's the
greatest human that ever existed i think
it disappeared but we need to keep
working on our own systems make our own
movies make our own shows 100 set up our
own websites if you're concerned about
censorship it doesn't mean abandon
twitter or youtube it means use the
other platforms minds for instance and
make your own website where they can't
ban you from your own site granted
financial services and third parties can
still come after you so
it's time to start building
infrastructure bro i'm building a
website right now to try to like
to try to keep myself there and every
time you think you figured out another
potential loophole that they could take
you down it's come down to like okay so
starting with building your own server
dude you can't even get emails it's like
yeah mailchimp deleted cancelled sorry
for bad politics we're not going to give
you your emails you're like great things
start mails that's why you have to go
okay email server internet provider
website hosting like you go where's who
like owns even the website domain and
you're going through this you're going
wow the reason why we haven't won this
yet is because we need a lot more smart
people and a lot more money not going
into nonprofits that are doing nothing
but into actually for profits and things
that can hire people and make a change
and we need to slow our thoughts down in
general i think you were saying like the
age of instant gratification and elijah
you were talking about how important it
is to be calculating and i think a lot
of people when offered a choice a b they
feel like they have to make the choice
and you don't not only do you not have
to answer the way people expect you to
you don't have to answer and you can
think about it you don't have to sign
the contract when it's handed to you you
can read it you can take as much time as
you want because it's your contract dude
people cap themselves so much and it's
insane to me like again this goes back
to our entire education system we're
taught to be subservient to authority
people think there's only option a and b
people don't see that they can do
whatever they want with their life you
can be tim poole if you want to if you
work hard enough you can do whatever you
want in this life but people think it's
like well if i'm gonna be a doctor i
just have to be a doctor that's it i
can't be good at anything else if i'm
gonna be on youtube i just have to be a
youtuber that's it nothing else people
cap themselves so much people should
should watch my old youtube videos and
just be like man that guy saw it were
they horrendous probably yeah really bad
dude the first time i was on with alex
i'm like embarrassed for people to pull
it up one day because it was horrific
yeah my hands are like this the whole
time
i'm like this that's my that's where i'm
at in my career me too dude he's like it
was horrible this is where i said
my current state all right
let's uh let's read this one more super
chat before we go to the members only
we've got brody nevis who says hey been
a fan of yours and crowder since 2016.
i'm 22 and i share your show and his to
my family but they still believe in the
same stuff as the left and i want to
leave ca what do i do to get out of here
and convince my family the left is wrong
if you can show your family that trayvon
martin michael brown jesse smallett the
covenant kids russia gate ahmed arbory
the list goes on all of those stories
were proven false
and they still believe it
i think it's on an issue of i think the
issue is more so
they know it's not true but they don't
want
to admit it
they're not smart enough to realize and
they'll keep falling for it
uh i think that's what you're dealing
with and if that's the case
you're going to be on your own and you
have to figure things out for yourself
yeah you got to impress them in the way
that they speak the language of like
when i talk to my mom i'll be like we're
making world-changing social media
technology and she'll be like oh that's
great are you making enough money honey
like she just cares that i'm making
money because that's her world so if you
want to impress those people you need to
entice them with their own language it's
annoying and if you don't want to do
that then don't you walk away from it i
think uh
you know
bet big win big play big win bigs they
say casinos high risk high rewards
i was uh i lived in chicago i had an
apartment
i took a ride share to california with
200 bucks in cash and that's how i moved
to l.a
and then i was that was it i was
homeless fortunately a friend of mine
had been out there and let me crash a
couple days and then i was like just
prepared to go live on the beach but i
found a job almost right away and then i
got lucky with this one someone let me
crash at their place so
i just i feel like
it's a question of
what are you willing to sacrifice and
the more you're willing to sacrifice the
bigger risk you're willing to take the
bigger rewards exist for you and for me
because i was like i honestly don't care
if i sleep outside that gave me more
freedom to find opportunities people
wouldn't normally take and if your
concern is you want a stable life and
you need a stable life you're going to
have a harder time scouting out and
finding opportunities
but you'll be stable you know you'll be
safe it's the image of stable though the
stability is not really that real there
is no no there's there's no stability
and this is not the um you know whatever
ego moment in real life but i mean this
genuinely there's a reason why it is
easier if you are not married and you
don't have children to take certain
risks genuinely i'm encouraging that
there's a reason why you don't see a lot
of stable married people even in this
industry specifically and whatever you
want to do to change the world it may
not be even that that possible meaning
i find that a lot of people that i've
met who do this for instance had a
homeless sort of pseudo-homeless time of
their life where they had to risk a lot
to get where they are i mean i lived on
the youtube reflections couch he
supported me financially in the
beginning i didn't make anybody until i
could monetize my channel and get it up
he was he came through and that guy was
probably like literally just the most
clutch person i've ever seen he was like
hey i know what this takes bro let's go
ahead and do it but for someone who left
who left california myself i encourage
you a few things number one like go to
go to go to my channel slightly
offensive look up like the homeless
people of la look up why i left
california then go to the videos that
are suggested after it you will see the
stories and i have a video with like
reflects where we both i mean i'm born
and raised in california we literally
talk about all the reasons why we're
leaving and there are videos on youtube
and they're entertaining and they're
done in a funny way just to say hey a b
c and d
as you stay here and give tax dollars
you support this and if you don't then
get out and that's what a lot of us did
we are going to go to the members only
segment so if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it that's the most powerful thing
you can do uh go to timcast.com we're
going to have up at about 11 p.m the
members only show which is going to get
very spicy i can already i can already
tell and you can follow the show at tim
cast irl basically everywhere except
tick tock where we're banned you can
follow me at tim cast basically
everywhere elijah you want to shout
anything out yeah um you know obviously
if you're uh wanting to watch a podcast
that is pure insanity go to youtube.com
slightly offensive it has been so insane
and so crazy president zielenski was on
our last episode trying to shill
ukrainian vodka it's just crazy and also
you can catch us live at uh 6 p.m
central on you are here but of course
don't compete with tim cast at the hour
uh but we appreciate you guys and um and
make sure you can find me on every
social media and all social media from
gab i am on gutter and twitter and some
of the other ones but uh
yeah but but i'm pretty much everywhere
where people are because i don't give a
crap about the companies and as much as
trying to get the content out so follow
me they're slightly offensive and you
are here
savannah all right guys uh thank you
again for having me on you guys can go
follow me since i've been twice banned
on twitter now my on the ground
reporting will live primarily on truth
social at sap says and instagram at sav
with one end i have my own youtube
channel staff says go check it out and i
also have my own podcast called rapid
fire with savannah hernandez where i
talk about political commentary and my
on-the-ground reporting also
sapphiresofficial.com my website go
check it out and uh again thank you guys
so much oh so much fun thanks for coming
man it's great to meet you finally i
know i'm so happy you're a wonderful man
i love you so much that is the nicest
thing
people
tim knows this too it's like some people
that hate watch like you like open up
your dms it's like stuff like you can't
even read
like i can't read it i always like to
post i'm like i guess people love me so
much they hate me
that's true oh i have um
a beat on musa's new album which is
coming out do you know what guys know
what it's called no what is that people
will love the people nice this is tim's
single i don't know if you know that
because they're singing on it
i don't know anything about it yet but
there was the ta the name of tim's first
singles will of the people it's really
like matthew bellamy saw and he was like
i gotta do it
either that or there's something about
the will of the people that we need to
pay attention to maybe maybe a little
bit yeah yeah who's controlling the will
of the people and you'll have to cut
you'll have to come on uh you'll have to
come on on my show yeah i'm definitely
slightly offensive so you can talk about
crystals and demons yeah and magic and
let's talk about space trails
we need to do it okay
i'm excited yeah anyway thank you guys
both very much for coming i just want to
say before i go this is just my two
cents i have to throw out there i
appreciate what elijah had to say about
incrementally adjusting your resistance
to what's going on in the world today i
think that's a great idea i would
strongly recommend doing things like
saving up money trying to make sure
you're prepared for whatever happens and
then you can kind of push back according
to your own personal values you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sour patch lids i want to address just
one quick super chat from mike doyle
says that uh he's lost access to the
website but he's still being charged
there was there's an issue with paypal
that uh they can't fix i suppose and we
are working to fix but it's it's it's a
weird time getting thing where it's like
the year anniversary when people signed
up something weird triggers
so we are working to fix that at the
same time we are also working on
implementing a new alternative system
that will be resilient and we're going
to announce it once it's ready and it's
going to be fantastic because we want to
make sure we're working with companies
who believe in free speech we wanna
over the next you know year or so as we
expand
separate ourselves from companies that
hate us and start working towards and
with companies that don't hate us and
that's our plan which means there's
going to be changes to um membership not
for no one should really notice anything
but we're going to we're going to have
like a new better system and it's going
to be really really awesome so stay
tuned for that you guys are going to
love the news that we have but uh that
being said we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you